the wake-up call
he collapsed right in the middle of a
packed courtroom he was one of this
country's most distinguished trial
lawyers
he was also a man well known for the
three thousand dollar italian suits
which draped his well-fed frame as for
his remarkable string of legal victories
i simply stood there paralyzed by the
shock of what i just witnessed
the great julian mantle had been reduced
to a victim and was now squirming on the
ground like a helpless infant shaking
and shivering like a maniac
i had known julian for 17 years we had
first met when i was a young law student
hired as a summer research intern back
then he'd headed all he was a brilliant
handsome and fearless trial attorney
with dreams of greatness
julian was the firm's young star he was
tough hard driving and willing to work
18-hour days for the success he believed
was his destiny
julian's outrageous courtroom theatrics
regularly made the front pages of the
newspapers his extracurricular
activities were probably as well known
late night visits to the city's finest
restaurants with sexy young fashion
models or reckless drinking escapades
became the stuff of legend
i still can't figure out why he picked
me to work with him on that sensational
murder case he was to argue that first
summer
though i had graduated from harvard law
school his alma mater i certainly wasn't
the brightest intern at the firm at
julian's invitation i stayed on at the
firm as an associate and a lasting
friendship quickly developed between us
i will admit that he wasn't the easiest
lawyer to work with
serving as his junior was often an
exercise in frustration leading to more
than a few late night shouting matches
however beneath his crusty exterior was
a person who clearly cared about people
no matter how busy he was he would
always ask about jenny the woman i still
call my bride
and finding out that i was in a
financial squeeze julian arranged for me
to receive a generous scholarship
sure he could play hardball with the
best of them but he never neglected his
friends
the real problem was that julian was
obsessed with work
for the first few years he justified his
long hours by saying that he was doing
it for the good of the firm
as time passed julian's reputation for
brilliance spread and his workload
continued to increase in his rare
moments of quiet confided that he could
no longer sleep for more than a couple
of hours without waking up feeling
guilty that he was not working on a file
it soon became clear to me that he was
being consumed by the hunger for more
more prestige
more glory and more money
as expected julian became enormously
successful he achieved everything most
people could ever want
a stellar professional reputation with
an income in seven figures a spectacular
mansion a private jet and his prized
possession
a shiny red ferrari parked in the center
of his driveway
at 53 years of age julian looked as if
he was in his late 70s his face was a
massive wrinkles a less than glorious
tribute to his take no prisoners
approach to life in general and to the
tremendous stress of his out of balance
lifestyle in particular
his late night dinners in expensive
french restaurants smoking thick cuban
cigars and drinking cognac after cognac
had left him embarrassingly overweight
he constantly complained that he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
julian's once enthusiastic nature had
been replaced by a deathly somberness
personally i think that his life had
lost all sense of purpose
almost every day he would tell me that
he felt no passion for what he was doing
and was enveloped by emptiness
julian said that as a young lawyer he
really loved the law
the law's complexities and intellectual
challenges had kept him spellbound and
full of energy
its power to affect social change
inspired and motivated him
that vision gave his life meaning it
gave him a purpose and it fueled his
hopes
there was even more to julian's undoing
than a rusty connection to what he did
for a living
he had suffered some great tragedy
before i had joined the firm something
truly unspeakable had happened to him
but i couldn't get anyone to open up
about it
whatever this deep dark secret was i had
a suspicion that it in some way was
contributing to julian's downward spiral
sure i was curious but most of all i
wanted to help him he was not only my
mentor
he was my best friend
and then it happened this massive heart
attack brought the brilliant julian
mantle back down to earth and
reconnected him to his mortality
the mysterious visitor
it was an emergency meeting of all of
the firm's members
old man harding was the first to speak
to the assembled mass
i'm afraid i have some very bad news
julian mantle suffered a severe heart
attack in court yesterday
he is currently in the intensive care
unit but his physicians have informed me
that his condition is now stabilized and
he will recover
however
julian has made a decision to leave our
family and to give up his law practice
he will not be returning to the firm
i was shocked
i knew he was having a share of troubles
but i never thought he would quit
as well after all we had been through i
thought he would at least have the
courtesy to tell me this personally he
wouldn't even see me at the hospital
maybe i reminded him of the life he
wanted to forget
who knows
i'll tell you one thing though
it hurt
that whole episode was just over three
years ago last i heard julian had headed
off to india on some kind of expedition
he told one of the partners that he
wanted to simplify his life and that he
needed some answers and hoped he would
find them in that mystical land
he sold his mansion and his plane
he had even sold his ferrari
as those three years passed i changed
from an overworked young lawyer to a
jaded somewhat cynical older lawyer
my wife jenny and i had a family
eventually i began my own search for
meaning
i think it was having kids that did it
my dad said it best when he said john on
your deathbed you will never wish you
spent more time at the office
so i started spending a little bit more
time at home
i settled into a pretty good if ordinary
existence
i joined the rotary club and played golf
on saturdays to keep my partners and
clients happy
but i must tell you in my quiet moments
i often thought of julian
no one had received even a postcard from
him since he left for his self-imposed
exile from the law
a knock on my door about two months ago
offered the first answers to some of my
questions i just met with my last client
on a grueling day when genevieve my
brainy legal assistant popped her head
into my office
there's someone here to see you john
he says it's urgent and he will not
leave until he speaks with you
for an instant i considered calling
security but realizing that this might
be someone in need i assumed a more
forgiving posture
okay send him in i probably could use
the business anyway
the door to my office opened slowly at
last it swung fully open revealing a
smiling man in his mid-thirties he was
tall
lean and muscular radiating an abundance
of vitality and energy
but there was more to my visitor than
his youthful good looks
an underlying peacefulness gave him an
almost divine presence
and his eyes piercing blue eyes that
sliced clear through me
the young man continued to look at me
much as the smiling buddha might have
looked upon a favored pupil
after a long moment of uncomfortable
silence he spoke in a surprisingly
commanding tone
is this how you treat all of your
visitors john he said his full lips
curling into a mighty grin
a strange sensation tickled the pit of
my stomach
julian
is that you i can't believe it
is it really you
the loud laugh if the visitor confirmed
my suspicions
the young man standing before me was
none other than that long lost yogi of
india julian mantle i was dazzled by his
incredible transformation
gone was the ghost-like complexion the
sickly cough and the lifeless eyes of my
former colleague
perhaps even more astounding was the
serenity that julian exuded i felt
entirely peaceful just sitting there
staring at him
the man before me was a youthful
vital and smiling model of change
the miraculous transformation of julian
mantle
[Music]
julian was the first to speak
he admitted that his body had fallen
apart and that his mind had lost its
luster
the constant pressure and exhausting
schedule of a world-class trial lawyer
had also broken his most important and
perhaps most human endowment his spirit
when given the ultimatum by his doctor
either to give up the law or give up his
life
he said he saw a golden opportunity to
rekindle the inner fire that he had
known when he was younger
julian grew visibly excited as he
recounted how he sold all his material
possessions and headed for india a land
whose ancient culture and mystical
traditions had always fascinated him
he traveled from tiny village to tiny
village seeing the timeless sights and
growing to love the indian people
julian slowly began to feel alive and
whole again perhaps for the first time
since he was a child
his natural curiosity and creative spark
steadily returned along with his
enthusiasm and his energy for living
he started to feel more joyful and
peaceful
and he began to laugh again
julian told me that his journey to india
was more than a simplification
he described his time as a personal
odyssey of the self
he confided that he was determined to
find out who he really was and what his
life was all about
to do this his first priority was to
connect to that culture's vast pool of
ancient wisdom on living a more
rewarding fulfilling and enlightened
life
the more he explored the more he heard
of indian monks who had lived beyond the
age of a hundred
monks who despite their advanced years
maintained youthful energetic and vital
lives
the more he traveled the more he learned
of ageless yogis who had mastered the
art of mind control and spiritual
awakening
it was while he was in kashmir an
ancient and mystical state that sits
sleepily at the foot of the himalayas
that he had the good fortune to meet a
gentleman named yogi krishnan
this slight man with a clean shaven head
had also been a lawyer
fed up with his hectic pace that
personifies modern new delhi he too gave
up his material possessions and
retreated to a world of greater
simplicity
becoming a caretaker of the village
temple krishnan said he had come to know
himself and his purpose in the larger
scheme of life
julian informed this lawyer turned yogi
off his own story
i need your help krishnan i need to
learn how to build a richer fuller life
for as long as i've been caring for this
temple i've heard whisperings of a
mystical band of sages living high in
the himalayas
legend has it that they have discovered
some sort of system that will profoundly
improve the quality of anyone's life
it is supposed to be a holistic
integrated set of ageless principles and
timeless techniques to liberate the
potential of the mind
body and soul
julian was fascinated this seemed
perfect
just exactly where these monks live
no one knows and i regret that i am too
old to start searching but i will tell
you one thing my friend many have tried
to find them and many have failed
the higher reaches of the himalayas are
treacherous beyond consequences
but if it is the golden keys to radiant
health lasting happiness and inner
fulfillment that you are searching for
i do not have the wisdom you seek
they do
[Music]
are you certain that you have no idea
where they live all i can tell you is
that the locals in this village know
them as the great sages of savannah
in their mythology savannah means oasis
of enlightenment
these monks are revered as if they are
divine in their constitution and
influence if i knew where they could be
found i would be duty-bound to tell you
the next morning julian set out to the
lost land of savannah
the first few days were easy
sometimes he would catch up to one of
the cheerful citizens of the village
walking on one of the footpaths at other
times he hiked alone
the majesty of the snow-capped peaks of
the himalayas made his heartbeat faster
and for one moment took his breath away
the fresh mountain air cleared his mind
and energized his spirit
at once he felt joyous exhilarated and
carefree
it was here high above the humanity
below that julian slowly ventured out of
the cocoon of the ordinary and began to
explore the realm of the extraordinary
it was while he was soaking in the gifts
of nature's intelligence that something
startling happened
from the corner of his eye he saw
another figure dressed strangely in a
long flowing red robe topped by a dark
blue hood slightly ahead of him on the
path
julian was astonished to see anyone in
this isolated spot that had taken him
seven treacherous days to reach he
yelled out to his fellow traveler
the figure refused to respond and
accelerated his pace along the path they
were both climbing
soon the mysterious traveler was running
his red robe dancing gracefully behind
him
please friend i need your help to find
savannah yelled julian i've been
traveling for seven days with little
food and water i think i'm lost
the figure came to an abrupt stop
julian approached cautiously while the
traveler stood remarkably still and
silent
his head did not move his hands did not
move and his feet kept their place
julian gazed at the traveler with an
intense curiosity
a quick burst of a sunbeam revealed that
it was a man's face under the loosely
fitting hood
though he was at least his own age there
were very striking features of this
person which left julian mesmerized
his eyes were cad-like and so
penetrating the julian was forced to
look away
his olive complexion skin was supple and
smooth his body looked strong and
powerful
and though the man's hands gave away the
fact that he was not young
he radiated an abundance of youthfulness
and vitality
i am julian mantle i have come to learn
from the sages of savannah do you know
where i might find them
the man spoke softly
why is it that you seek these sages
friend
sensing that he had indeed found one of
the mystical monks who had eluded so
many julian opened his heart and poured
out his odyssey to the traveler
he spoke of his former life and of the
crisis of spirit he had struggled with
and he told of his travels in mystical
india and of his meeting with yogi
krishnan
the traveler remained silent and still
it was not until julian spoke of his
burning almost obsessive desire to
acquire the ancient principles of
enlightened living that the man spoke
again
placing an arm on julian's shoulder the
man said gently
if you truly have a heartfelt desire to
learn the wisdom of a better way then it
is my duty to help you
i am indeed one of those sages that you
have come so far in search of if you
like you may come with me as my guest to
our temple
my brothers and sisters will welcome you
with open arms we will work together to
teach you the ancient principles and
strategies that our ancestors have
passed down through the ages
before i take you into our private world
i must request one promise from you
upon learning these timeless truths you
must return to your homeland in the west
and share this wisdom with all those who
need to hear it
though we are isolated in these magical
mountains we are aware of the turmoil
your world is in
good people are losing their way
you must give them the hope that they
deserve more importantly you must give
them the tools to fulfill their dreams
this is all i ask
julian instantly accepted the sage's
terms as the two men moved still higher
up the mountain path to the lost village
of savannah the indian sun started to
set
a fiery red circle slipping into a soft
magical slumber after a long and weary
day
a magical meeting with the sages of
savannah
after walking for many hours the two
travelers came upon a lush green valley
on one side of the valley the
snow-capped himalayas offered their
protection
on the other a thick forest of pine
trees sprouted
the sage looked at julian and smiled
gently
welcome to the nirvana of savannah
the two then descended into the thick
forest which formed the floor of the
valley
the smell of pine in sandalwood wafted
through the cool crisp mountain air
julian now barefoot to ease his aching
feet felt the damp moss under his toes
he was surprised to see the richly
colored orchids and a host of other
lovely flowers dancing among the trees
after walking for about 15 more minutes
the two men reached a clearing
before him was a sight that even the
worldly wise and rarely surprised julian
mantle could never have imagined
a small village made solely out of what
appeared to be roses
at the center of the village was a tiny
temple made of red white and pink
flowers held together with long strands
of multicolored string and twigs
the little huts which dotted the
remaining space appeared to be the
austere homes of the sages these were
also made of roses
julian was speechless
julian's traveling companion now
revealed that his name was yogi ramen
he explained that he was the eldest sage
of savannah and the leader of the group
the citizens of this dreamlike colony
looked astonishingly youthful and moved
with poise and purpose
none of them spoke choosing instead to
respect the tranquility of this place by
performing their tasks in silence the
men who appeared to number only about 10
wore the same red robed uniform as yogi
ramen and smiled serenely at julian
each of them looked calm healthy and
deeply contented
the women were equally impressive
in their flowing pink silk sarees and
with white lotuses adorning their jet
black hair they moved busily through the
village with exceptional agility
with zen-like focus some worked inside
the temple preparing for what appeared
to be a festival
others carried firewood and richly
embroidered tapestries
all were engaged in productive
activities
all appeared to be happy
ultimately the faces of the sages of
savannah revealed the power of their way
of life
even though they were clearly mature
adults each one of them radiated a
childlike quality their eyes twinkling
with the vitality of youth
not one of them had wrinkles not one of
them had gray hair
not one of them looked old
[Music]
julian was offered a feast of fresh
vegetables and fruits a diet that he
would later learn was one of the keys to
the ideal health enjoyed by the sages
after the meal yogi ramen escorted
julian to his living quarters a
flower-filled hut containing a small bed
with an empty journal pad on it
this would be his home for the
foreseeable future
though julian had never seen anything
like this magical world of savannah his
intuition told him that he belonged here
if only for a short period
and so began julian's life among the
sages of savannah a life of simplicity
serenity and harmony
the best was soon to come
a spiritual student of the sages
[Music]
it was now 8 pm and i still had to
prepare for court the next day yet i was
fascinated by the experience of this
former legal warrior
the longer i listened to julian the more
i came to realize that my own spirit had
become rusty what had happened to the
uncommon passion i brought to everything
i did when i was younger maybe it was
time for me to reinvent my destiny
julian quickened the pace as he
continued with his tale
he told me how his desire for knowledge
coupled with his sharp intellect had
made him a well-loved member of the
savannah community
as a mark of their affection for julian
the monks eventually made him an
honorary member of their band and
treated him like an integral part of
their extended family
eager to expand his knowledge of the
workings of the mind body and soul and
to attain self-mastery julian spent
literally every waking moment under the
tutelage of yogi ramen
the sage became more like a father to
julian than a teacher
it was clear that this man had the
accumulated wisdom of many lifetimes and
most happily he was willing to share it
with julian
beginning before dawn yogi ramon would
sit with his enthusiastic student and
fill his mind with insights on the
meaning of life and little known
techniques for living with greater
vitality creativity and fulfillment
he taught julian ancient principles
anyone could use to live longer stay
younger and grow far happier
julian also learned how the twin
disciplines of personal mastery and
self-responsibility would keep him from
returning to the chaos of crisis that
had characterized his life in the west
julian said that the first indications
of his personal expansion came after
only three weeks in savannah
he also said that his new lifestyle and
the new habits associated with it
started to have a profound effect on his
inner world
within a month of applying the
principles and techniques of the sages
he had begun to cultivate the deep sense
of peace and inner serenity that had
eluded him
he became more joyful and spontaneous
growing more energetic and creative with
each passing day
after pausing as if to express disbelief
at his own tale julian grew
philosophical
i've realized that the world and that
includes my inner world is a very
special place
i've learned that self-mastery and the
consistent care of one's mind body and
soul are essential to finding one's
highest self and living the life of
one's dreams
how can you care for others if you
cannot even care for yourself
i can't love you if i cannot love myself
he offered
suddenly julian grew flustered i've
never opened my heart to anyone like
this before it is just that i
experienced such a catharsis up in those
mountains such a spiritual awakening to
the powers of the universe that i feel
others need to know what i know
noticing it was getting late julian
quickly told me he would take his leave
and bid me a jeer
i'll be back my friend
you have your work to do and i have some
private matters that need to be taken
care of
just tell me one thing
will the methods you learned in savannah
work for me
when the student is ready the teacher
appears came the swift reply
you along with so many others are ready
for the wisdom i now have the privilege
of holding
i will meet you again tomorrow night
this time at your house
then i'll tell you all you need to know
to put far more living into your life
and with that the master litigator
turned enlightened yogi of the east was
gone
the wisdom of personal change
true to his word julian showed up at my
house the next evening
he still embodied radiant health and
exuded a wonderful sense of calm
it was what he was wearing that made me
a little uncomfortable
adorning his obviously supple body was a
long red robe topped by an ornately
embroidered blue hood
greetings my friend julian offered
enthusiastically greetings
don't look so alarmed what did you
expect me to wear armani
we both started to laugh softly at first
soon our giggles had turned into guffaws
julian certainly had not lost that
wicked sense of humor
as we relax in my cluttered but
comfortable living room i couldn't help
but notice the ornate necklace of wooden
prayer beads dangling from his neck
what are those they're really beautiful
more about these later he said we have
much to talk about tonight
let's get started i could hardly get
anything done at work today i was so
excited about our meeting
julian immediately started to reveal
more about his personal transformation
and the ease with which it was affected
he told me of the ancient techniques he
had learned from mind control and for
erasing the habit of worry
though the conviction with which he
spoke was clear i began to grow
skeptical
was i the victim of some prank this
could not be real
come on julian stop pulling my leg this
whole story is starting to smack of one
of your gags i suggested breaking into
my best fear grin
julian remained calm and patient
spotting the pot of tea i had left on
the table next to him he started to pour
into my waiting cup
he poured until the cup was full but
then he kept on pouring
tea started to trickle down the sides of
the cup and into the saucer
julian what are you doing my cup is
overflowing no matter how hard you try
no more will go in
he looked at me for a long moment
please don't take this the wrong way i
really respect you john
however just like this cup you seem full
of your own ideas and how can any more
go in
until you first empty your cup
i was struck by the truth of his words
my many years in the conservative legal
world doing the same things every day
with the same people who thought the
same thoughts every day had filled my
cup to the brim
okay i see your point i admitted perhaps
all my years as a trial lawyer have made
me a hardened skeptic from the minute i
saw you yesterday something deep inside
me told me that your transformation was
genuine maybe i just didn't want to
believe it
john tonight is the first night of your
new life i simply ask that you think
deeply about the wisdom and strategies
that i will share with you and apply
them with conviction for a period of one
month
you will experience changes within the
workings of your mind body and even your
soul that will astonish you
a lasting sense of well-being and
balance will swiftly return to your life
wow
the advice of the sages is just as
current today as it was five thousand
years ago it will not only enrich your
inner world it will enhance your outer
world and make you far more effective in
all that you do
most importantly it will work for anyone
but before i share this knowledge with
you i must ask you for a promise
once you see the power of the strategies
and skills shown to me by the sages of
savannah you must make it your mission
to pass this wisdom on to others who
will benefit from this knowledge
by agreeing to do this you will help me
fulfill my own pact with yogi ramen
i agreed without reservation
julian began to teach me the system he
had come to consider as sacred at the
heart of the savannah system were seven
basic virtues seven fundamental
principles which embodied the keys to
self-leadership personal responsibility
and spiritual enlightenment
julian told me that yogi ramon was the
first to share the seven virtues with
him after a few months in savannah
on a clear night ramen knocked softly on
the door of julian's hut in the voice of
a gentle guide he spoke his mind
since you have arrived you have opened
yourself up to our traditions and
embraced them as your own tonight on the
eve of your third month in savannah i
will begin to share the inner workings
of our system with you not only for your
benefit but for the benefit of all those
in your part of the world
i feel grateful that all i have learned
over many years of silent contemplation
will live within you
i looked at julian and noticed that his
eyes were now shut as if he were
transporting himself back to this
fairytale land that had showered the
blessing of knowledge on him
yogi ramen told me that the seven
virtues for a life overflowing with
inner peace
joy and a wealth of spiritual gifts were
contained within a mystical fable this
fable was the essence of it all
he asked me to shut my eyes as i have
now done here on the floor of your
living room
he then told me to picture the following
scene in my mind's eye
[Music]
you are sitting in the middle of a
magnificent lush green garden
this garden is filled with the most
spectacular flowers you have ever seen
the environment is supremely tranquil
and silent savor the sensual delights of
this garden and feel as if you have all
the time in the world to enjoy this
natural oasis
as you look around you see that in the
center of this magical garden stands a
towering red lighthouse six stories high
suddenly the silence of the garden is
disturbed by a loud creaking as the door
at the base of the lighthouse opens
out stumbles a nine foot tall 900 pound
japanese sumo wrestler who casually
wanders into the center of the garden
it gets better chuckled julian the
japanese sumo wrestler is naked
well actually he's not totally naked he
has a pink wire cable covering his
private parts
as the sumo wrestler starts to move
around the garden
he finds a shiny gold stopwatch which
someone had left behind many years
earlier he slips on it and falls to the
ground with an enormous thud
the sumo wrestler is rendered
unconscious and lies there silent and
still
just when you think he has taken his
last breath the wrestler awakens stirred
by the fragrance of some fresh yellow
roses blooming nearby
energized the wrestler jumps swiftly to
his feet and intuitively looks to his
left he is startled by what he sees
through the bushes at the very edge of
the garden he observes a long winding
path covered by millions of sparkling
diamonds
something seems to instruct the wrestler
to take the path and to his credit he
does
this path leads him down the road of
everlasting joy and eternal bliss
after hearing the strange tale julian
told me he was disappointed
he had expected to hear something
earth-shattering wisdom that would stir
him to action and perhaps even move him
to tears
yogi ramen detected this and said at
first it might seem to be frivolous and
perhaps even childish
but i assure you that every element of
the fable embodies a timeless principle
for radiant living and has great depth
of meaning
the garden the lighthouse the sumo
wrestler the pink wire cable the
stopwatch the roses and the winding path
of diamonds are symbols of the seven
timeless virtues for an enlightened life
i can also assure you that if you
remember this little story and the
fundamental truths that it represents
you will carry within you all that you
need to know to raise your life to its
highest level
you will have all the information and
strategies you will need to profoundly
influence the quality of your life and
the lies of all those you touch
and when you apply this wisdom on a
daily basis you will change mentally
emotionally physically and spiritually
[Music]
a most extraordinary garden
in the fable the garden is a symbol for
the mind said julian
if you care for your mind if you nurture
it and cultivate it just like a fertile
rich garden it will blossom far beyond
your expectations
but if you let the weeds take root
lasting peace of mind and deep inner
harmony will always elude you
look at the toxic waste that most people
put into the fertile garden of their
minds every single day the worries and
anxieties the fretting about the past
the brooding over the future and those
self-created fears that wreak havoc
within your inner world
worry drains the mind of much of its
power and sooner or later it injures the
soul
to live life to the fullest you must
stand guard at the gate of the garden of
your mind and let only the best
information enter
you truly can't afford the luxury of a
negative thought not even one the most
joyful dynamic and contented people of
this world are no different from you or
me in terms of their makeup
however the ones who do more than just
exist the ones who fan the flames of
their human potential and truly savor
the magical dance of life do different
things than those whose lives are
ordinary
foremost among the things they do is
adopt a positive paradigm about their
world and all that is in it
the way you think stems from habit pure
and simple julian continued with
conviction
i have learned that even the best
conditioned thinkers are using only one
one hundredth of one percent of their
mental reserves
in savannah the sages dared to explore
the untapped potential of their mental
capacity on a regular basis and the
results were astounding
yogi raman through regular and
disciplined practice had conditioned his
mind so that he was able to slow down
his heartbeat at will
he'd even trained himself to go for
weeks without sleep
while i would never suggest that these
should be goals for you to aspire to i
do suggest that you start to see your
mind for what it is nature's greatest
gift
my teacher was growing more excited by
the moment his eyes seemed to twinkle as
he spoke of the magic of the mind and
the wealth of goodness it would surely
bring
there is no such thing as objective
reality or the real world there are no
absolutes
an event that appears to be a tragedy to
one might reveal the seeds of unlimited
opportunity to another
what really separates people who are
habitually upbeat and optimistic from
those who are consistently miserable is
how the circumstances of their life are
interpreted and processed
it all starts with using your mind more
effectively
exactly john
all success in life whether material or
spiritual starts with that 12-pound mass
sitting between your shoulders
your outer world reflects the state of
your inner world by controlling the
thoughts that you think and the way you
respond to the events of your life you
begin to control your destiny
this makes so much sense julian
i guess my life has become so busy that
i have never taken the time to think
about these things
when i was in law school my best friend
alex used to love reading inspirational
books he said that they kept him
motivated and energized in the face of
our crushing workload i remember him
telling me that one of them said that
the chinese character for crisis is
comprised of two sub-characters
one that spells danger and another that
spells opportunity
i guess that even the ancient chinese
knew that there is a bright side to the
darkest circumstance if you have the
courage to look for it
yogi ramen put it this way there are no
mistakes in life only lessons
there is no such thing as a negative
experience only opportunities to grow
learn and advance along the road of
self-mastery from struggle comes
strength
even pain can be a wonderful teacher
pain i protested
absolutely to transcend pain you must
first experience it or to put it another
way how can you really know the joy of
being on the summit of the mountain
unless you have first visited the lowest
valley get my point
to savor the good one must know the bad
yes but i suggest that you stop judging
events as either positive or negative
rather simply experience them celebrate
them and learn from them
once you consistently apply this
principle to your daily life and start
to condition your mind to translate
every event into a positive empowering
one you will banish worry forever you
will stop being a prisoner of your past
instead you will become the architect of
your future
okay i understand the concept
what else might a humble middle class
lawyer do to improve things
first of all begin to live out of the
glory of your imagination not your
memory
run that one by me again
you see things are always created twice
first in the workshop of the mind and
then and only then in reality
i call the process blueprinting because
anything you create in your outer world
began as a simple blueprint in your
inner world
on the lush picture screen of your mind
when you learn to take control of your
thoughts and vividly imagine all that
you desire from this worldly existence
in a state of total expectancy dormant
forces will awaken inside you
you will begin to unlock the true
potential of your mind to create the
kind of magical life that i believe you
deserve
from tonight onwards forget about the
past
dare to dream that you are more than the
sum of your current circumstances expect
the best you will be astonished at the
results
i began to reflect on my own life when i
was a kid i dreamed such great dreams
often i visualized myself as a sports
hero or a business tycoon
i really believed that i could do have
or be whatever i wanted to be there were
no limits on what my future could bring
i honestly don't think i felt that kind
of freedom and joy for 15 years
what happened
perhaps i lost sight of my dream when i
became an adult and resigned myself to
acting the way adults were supposed to
act
maybe i lost sight of them when i went
to law school and started talking like
lawyers were supposed to talk
in any event that evening with julian at
my side made me resolve to stop spending
so much time making a living and to
spend far more time creating a life
[Music]
looks like i have you thinking about
your life also julian observed
start thinking about your dreams for a
change just like when you were a little
child start to revere life again and
celebrate all of its wonders
julian then reached into the depths of
his robe and pulled out a little card
one day while yogi ramen and i were
walking along a quiet mountain path i
asked him who his favorite philosopher
was
he told me that he had many influences
in his life and it was difficult for him
to single out any one source for his
inspiration
there was one quotation however that
encapsulated all the values he had come
to cherish over a life spent in quiet
contemplation the words came from the
great indian philosopher patanjali
repeating them aloud every morning
before i sit down to meditate has had a
profound influence on the course of my
day
julian then showed me the card
the quotation read
when you are inspired by some great
purpose some extraordinary project
all of your thoughts break their bonds
your mind transcends limitations your
consciousness expands in every direction
and you find yourself in a new great and
wonderful world
dormant forces faculties and talents
become alive and you discover yourself
to be a greater person than you ever
dreamed yourself to be
in that instant i saw the connection
between physical vitality and mental
agility
julian was in picture-perfect health and
looked many years younger than he had
when we had first met
success on the outside indeed begins
with success on the inside and by
changing his thoughts
julian had changed his life
exactly how can i develop this positive
serene and inspired attitude julian
after all these years in my routine i
think my mental muscles have grown a
little flabby i said with sincerity
if you diligently apply the strategies i
am sharing with you every day for only
one month you will be astonished at the
results you will begin to tap into the
highest levels of your own capacity and
enter the realm of the miraculous
but to reach this destination you must
not get hung up on the outcome instead
enjoy the process of personal expansion
and growth
julian added softly
before i give you the precise methods
passed on to me by the sages of savannah
i must first share a couple of key
principles
first always remember that concentration
is at the root of mental mastery
the very fact that you have a desire or
a dream means that you have the
corresponding capacity to realize it
[Music]
however to liberate the power of the
mind you must first be able to harness
it and direct its focus only to the task
at hand
the moment you concentrate the focus of
your mind on a singular purpose
extraordinary gifts will appear within
your life
how about eternal happiness
go big or stay home he chuckled nothing
like starting off small
well you can have that too
the secret of happiness is simple
find out what you truly love to do and
then direct all of your energy towards
doing it
once you're concentrating your mind
power and energy on a pursuit that you
love abundance flows into your life and
all your desires are fulfilled with ease
and grace
so simply figure out what turns you on
and then do it if it is a worthy pursuit
julian replied your passion must in some
way improve or serve the lives of others
once you find out what your life's work
is your world will come alive
you will wake up every morning with a
limitless reservoir of energy and
enthusiasm
all your thoughts will be focused on
your definite objective you will
automatically erase the worry habit and
become far more effective and productive
interestingly you will also have a deep
sense of inner harmony as if you are
somehow being guided to realize your
mission
it is a wonderful feeling i love it
julian offered gleefully
fascinating and i like the part about
getting up feeling good
to be really honest with you julian most
days i wish i could just stay under the
covers
do you know why most people sleep so
much
because they really don't have anything
else to do
those who rise with the sun all have one
thing in common
they all have a purpose that fans the
flames of their inner potential they are
driven by their priorities but not in an
unhealthy obsessive way
is more effortless and gentle than that
and given their enthusiasm and love for
what they are doing in their lives such
people live in the moment their
attention is fully and completely on the
task at hand therefore there are no
energy leaks
these people are the most vibrant and
vital individuals you will ever have the
good fortune to meet
energy leaks sounds a little new-agey
julian i'll bet you didn't learn that
one at harvard law school
true the sages of savannah pioneered
that concept though it has been around
for centuries its application is just as
relevant today
too many of us are consumed by needless
and endless worry
worry causes your precious mental energy
and potential to leak
soon you have no energy left
once you find your purpose however life
becomes much easier and far more
rewarding
when you figure out what your main aim
or destiny really is
your work will be play
wouldn't it be a little risky for me to
give up my job to start searching for my
overriding passion and purpose
i mean i have a family and real
obligations i have four people who
depend on me
i'm not saying that you have to leave
the legal profession tomorrow you will
however have to start taking risks
most people live within the confines of
their comfort zone yogi ramen was the
first to explain that the best thing you
can do for yourself is to regularly move
beyond it
this is the way to lasting personal
mastery and the realization of the true
potential of your human endowments
and what might those be
your mind your body and your soul
so what risks should i take
stop being so practical start doing the
things you have always wanted to do
i have known lawyers who have quit their
jobs to become stage actors and
accountants who have become jazz
musicians
in the process they have found the deep
happiness that had eluded them for so
long
calculated risk-taking will pay huge
dividends
i see your point
so take the time to think the sages of
savannah all took time daily to silently
contemplate not only where they were but
where they were going
they took the time to reflect on their
purpose and how they were living their
lives every day
most importantly they thought deeply and
genuinely about how they would improve
the next day
daily incremental improvements produce
lasting results which in turn lead to
positive change even 10 minutes of
focused reflection a day will have a
profound impact on the quality of your
life
hey you're going to share some
techniques with me julian i said hoping
to learn some practical ways to apply
the wisdom i was hearing
there is one technique for mastering the
mind which towers above all the rest
after practicing it for only 21 days i
felt more energetic enthusiastic and
vibrant that i had in years
the practice is over 4 000 years old
it's called the heart of the rose
all that you need to perform this
exercise is a fresh rose and a silent
place
natural surroundings are best but a
quiet room will do nicely
start to stare at the center of the rose
its heart
keep staring at the rose
notice its color its texture its design
savor its fragrance and think only about
this wonderful object in front of you
at first other thoughts will start
entering your mind distracting you from
the heart of the rose this is the mark
of an untrained mind
but you need not worry improvement will
come quickly
simply return your attention to the
object of your focus
soon your mind will grow strong and
disciplined
that's all there is to it sounds pretty
easy
that's the beauty of it john julian
replied however this ritual must be
performed daily for it to be effective
for the first few days you will find it
difficult to spend even five minutes in
this exercise persist
and spend longer and longer periods
savoring the heart of the rose after a
week or two you should be able to
perform the technique for 20 minutes
without your mind wandering to other
subjects
this will be the first indication that
you are taking back control of the
fortress of your mind
practically speaking you will notice
that you will feel far calmer you will
have taken a significant step towards
erasing the worry habit that plagues
most of the population you will enjoy
more energy and optimism
each day no matter how busy you get and
how many challenges you might face
return to the heart of the rose it is
your island of peace
never forget that there is power in
silence and in stillness
stillness is the stepping stone to
connecting with the universal source of
intelligence that throbs through every
living being
julian continued to reveal what he had
learned in savannah
another particularly good technique is
based on what yogi ramen called
opposition thinking
i learned that under the grand laws of
nature the mind can only hold one
thought at any one time
try it yourself john you will see that
it's true
[Music]
i did try it and it is true
using this little known information
anyone can easily create a positive
creative mindset within a short period
the process is straightforward when an
undesirable thought occupies the focal
point of your mind immediately replace
it with an uplifting one
this is where the prayer beads around my
neck come in julian added with rising
enthusiasm
every time i catch myself thinking a
negative thought i take this necklace
off and remove another bead these beads
of worry go into a cup i keep in my
knapsack
together they serve as gentle reminders
that i still have a distance to travel
on the road to mental mastery and
responsibility over the thoughts that
fill my mind
hey that's a great one this is really
practical stuff
i have never heard anything quite like
it
tell me more about this philosophy of
opposition thinking
let's say you've had a tough day in
court
the judge disagreed with your
interpretation of the law
the litigator on the other side belonged
in a cage and your client was more than
a little annoyed with your performance
you come home and fall into your
favorite chair full of gloom
step one is to become aware that you are
thinking these uninspiring thoughts
self-knowledge is the stepping stone to
self-mastery
step two is to appreciate once and for
all that just as easily as you allow
those gloomy thoughts to enter you can
replace them with cheerful ones
so think of the opposite of gloom
concentrate on being cheerful and
energetic
feel that you are happy
perhaps you might even start to smile
move your body as you do when you are
joyful and full of enthusiasm
sit up straight and breathe deeply and
train the power of your mind on positive
thoughts
you will notice a remarkable difference
in the way you feel within minutes
if you keep up your practice of
opposition thinking applying it to every
negative thought that habitually visits
your mind within weeks you will see that
they no longer hold any power
julian continued his explanation
thoughts are vital living things little
bundles of energy if you will
a strong disciplined mind which anyone
can cultivate through daily practice can
achieve miracles
i never saw thoughts as living things
julian i replied amazed at this
discovery
the sages of savannah firmly believe
that one should think only satwik or
pure thoughts if even one impure thought
entered the temple of their minds they
would punish themselves by traveling
many miles to an imposing waterfall and
standing under the ice cold water until
they could no longer bear the frigid
temperature
i thought you told me these sages were
wise
standing under an ice cold waterfall for
thinking one little negative thought
strikes me as extreme behavior
julian was lightning fast in his
response
john
i'll be blunt
you truly cannot afford the luxury of
even one negative thought
a worrisome thought is like an embryo it
starts off small but grows and grows
soon it takes on a life of its own
the sages of savannah had a wonderful
way to ensure that their thoughts were
pure and wholesome this technique was
also highly effective in manifesting
their desires however simple into
reality
the method will work for anyone
the technique was known to the sages as
the secret of the lake
to apply it these teachers would rise at
4am as they felt that the early morning
possessed magical qualities from which
anyone could benefit
the sages would then travel along a
series of steep narrow mountain paths
which eventually led them to the lower
reaches of the region they inhabited
once there they would walk along a
barely visible trail until they arrived
at a clearing
at the edge of the clearing was an aqua
blue lake covered by thousands of tiny
white lotuses
the water of the lake was strikingly
still and calm
it was a truly miraculous site
the sages told me that this lake had
been a friend to their ancestors over
the ages
julian explained that the sages would
look into the waters of the still lake
and envision their dreams becoming
reality
if it was the virtue of discipline they
wished to cultivate within their lives
they would picture themselves getting up
at dawn performing their rigorous
physical regimen without fail and
spending days in silence to enhance
their willpower
if it was courage they desired they
would picture themselves acting with
strength in a moment of crisis and
challenge
you see john the mind works through
pictures
pictures affect your self-image and your
self-image affects the way you feel
act and achieve
when you run inspiring imaginative
pictures through the movie screen of
your mind wonderful things start to
happen in your life
you must spend some time every day even
if it is just a few minutes in the
practice of creative envisioning
see yourself as you want to be whether
this means serving as a great judge
a great father
or a great citizen of your community
do i have to find a special lake to
apply the secret of the lake i asked
innocently
no you can practice this method in your
own living room or even at your office
if you really want to
shut the door hold all calls and close
your eyes
then take a few deep breaths
you will notice that after two or three
minutes you will start to feel relaxed
next visualize mental pictures of all
you want to be to have and to attain in
your life
if you want to be the world's best
father
envision yourself laughing and playing
with your kids responding to their
questions with an open heart
picture yourself acting gracefully and
lovingly in a tense situation
mentally rehearse the way you will
govern your actions when a similar scene
unfolds on the canvas of reality
the magic of visualization can be
applied to so many situations
consistent use of this method will also
bring you financial rewards along with
an abundance of material gain if this is
important to you
understand once and for all that your
mind has magnetic power to attract all
that you desire into your life
once you start to experience the joy
this ancient technique brings you will
realize the infinite potential of your
mind and begin to liberate the
storehouse of ability and energy that
currently sleeps within you
it was as if julian was speaking a
foreign tongue
i had never heard anyone speak of the
power of imaging and its profound
effects on every aspect of one's world
yet
deep inside i had faith in what julian
was saying
but doing these exercises at the office
julian my partners think i'm strange
enough as it is
do not be concerned with the judgment of
others as long as you know what you are
doing is right
you can do whatever you want to do as
long as it is correct according to your
conscience and your heart
never be ashamed of doing that which is
right decide on what you think is good
and then stick to it
it was now seven minutes past midnight
remarkably i didn't feel the least bit
tired when i shared this with julian he
smiled once again
you have learned yet another principle
for enlightened living
when you consistently direct your mind
to live in the present you will always
have boundless energy no matter what
time the clock reflects
kindling the inner fire
john i'd like to continue to share the
elements of yogi roman's fable with you
but i must confirm something
we are living in a very troubled world
negativity pervades it and many in our
society are like floating ships without
rudders weary souls searching for a
lighthouse that will keep them from
crashing against the rocky shores
you must serve as a captain of sorts i'm
placing my trust in you to take the
message of the sages of savannah to all
those who need to hear it
after consideration i promised julian
with conviction that i would accept this
assignment
he then continued passionately
the beauty of the whole exercise is that
as you strive to improve the lives of
others your own life will be elevated
into its highest dimensions
this truth is based on an ancient
paradigm for extraordinary living
on all ears
basically the sages of the himalayas
guided their lives by a simple rule
he who serves the most reaps the most
emotionally physically mentally and
spiritually
this is the way to inner peace and outer
fulfillment
i once read that people who study others
are wise but those who study themselves
are enlightened
here perhaps for the first time
i saw a man who truly knew himself
perhaps his highest self
this brings me to the lighthouse said
julian remaining focused on the task at
hand
i was wondering how that fit into yogi
ramen's fable
you will recall that in the middle of
the garden stood a magnificent
lighthouse
this symbol will remind you of yet
another ancient principle for
enlightened living
the purpose of life is a life of purpose
those who are truly enlightened know
what they want out of life emotionally
materially physically and spiritually
clearly defined priorities and goals for
every aspect of your life will serve a
role similar to that played by a
lighthouse offering you guidance and
refuge when the seas become rough
julian transported me back to the time
when yogi ramen examined this principle
with him
he recalled the sage's exact words
life is funny observed yogi ramen
one would think the less one worked the
more one would have the chance to
experience happiness
however the real source of happiness can
be stated in a word
achievement
lasting happiness comes from steadily
working to accomplish your goals and
advancing confidently in the direction
of your life's purpose
workaholic monks
quite the opposite
while the sages were tremendously
productive people their productivity was
not of the frenetic type
instead it was of the peaceful focused
zen-like kind
the sages of savannah did not waste time
their collective conscience told them
that their lives had a purpose and they
had a duty to fulfill
this is what yogi ramon said to me
achievement need not be of the material
sort
personally my objectives are to attain
peace of mind self mastery and
enlightenment
if i fail to accomplish these goals by
the end of my life i am certain that i
will die feeling unfulfilled and
dissatisfied
julian told me that this was the first
time he had heard any of his teachers in
savannah speak of their own mortality
and yogi ramen sensed this in my
expression
you need not worry my friend he said
i've already lived past the age of 100
and have no plans for a quick exit
my point is simply that when you clearly
know what aims you wish to achieve over
the course of your life be they material
emotional physical or even spiritual and
you spend your days accomplishing them
you will ultimately find eternal joy
your life will be as delightful as mine
and you will come to know a splendid
reality
but you must know your life's aim and
then manifest this vision into reality
by consistent action
we sages call this dharma which is the
sanskrit word for life's purpose
lifelong contentment will come from the
fulfillment of my dharma i asked
most certainly dharma is based upon the
ancient principle that says each one of
us has a heroic mission while we walk
this earth
we have all been granted a unique set of
gifts and talents that will readily
allow us to realize this life work
the key is to discover them and in doing
so discover the main objective of your
life
over the course of the next few hours i
learned from julian that all highly
developed fully actualized people
understand the importance of exploring
their talents uncovering their personal
purpose and then applying their human
gifts in the direction of this calling
the key is to have the discipline and
vision to see your heroic mission and to
ensure that it serves other people while
you realize it
is this a form of goal setting
goal setting is the starting point said
julian mapping out your objectives and
your goals releases the creative juices
which get you on the path of your
purpose
believe it or not yogi ramen and the
other sages were very hot on goals
you're kidding
highly effective monks who meditate all
night and said goals all day i love it
yogi ramen said
people spend their whole lives dreaming
of becoming happier living with more
vitality and having an abundance of
passion
yet they do not see the importance of
taking even 10 minutes a month to write
out their goals and to think deeply
about the meaning of their lives their
dharma
goal setting will make your life
magnificent your world will become
richer more delightful
and more magical
you see julian our ancestors have taught
us that setting clearly defined
objectives for what we desire in our
mental physical and spiritual world is
critical to the realization
anyone who wishes to improve the quality
of their inner as well as their outer
worlds would do well to take out a piece
of paper and start writing out their
life aims
at the very moment this is done
natural forces will come into play which
start to transform these dreams into
reality
what i was hearing fascinated me
when i was a football player in high
school my coach had constantly spoken up
the importance of knowing what we wanted
from every game
our team wouldn't dream of stepping onto
the playing field without a clear game
plan that would lead us to victory i
wondered why as i had grown older i had
never taken the time to develop a game
plan for my own life
maybe julian and yogi ramen had
something here
what is so special about writing at your
goals how could such a simple act make
such a difference i asked
julian was delighted by writing out your
desires and goals on a piece of paper
you send a red flag to your subconscious
mind that these thoughts are far more
important than any others
you change your life the moment you set
your goals and start to seek out your
dharma julian said his eyes sparkling
with the truth of his words
have you ever met someone with a strange
name and then started to notice that
name appearing in newspapers on
television or at the office
this is but one illustration of the
ageless principle yogi ramen called joe
ricky which i have since learned means
concentrated mind
concentrate every ounce of your mental
energy on self-discovery
learn what you excel at and what makes
you happy whatever it is find your
passion and then follow it
now that i really think about it it
would be sad to reach the end of my life
without realizing that i had some
special genius that would have unlocked
my potential and helped others even in a
small way
that's right so from this moment onwards
be acutely aware of your aim in life
awaken your mind to the abundance of
possibility around you
start to live with more zest the human
mind is the world's largest filtering
device
when you decide to start concentrating
your mind on your life's main aims your
mind starts to filter out the
unimportant and focus only on the
important
to tell you the truth i think it's about
time i discovered my purpose i said
don't get me wrong there are a lot of
great things in my life but it isn't as
rewarding as i think it could be
how does that make you feel
depressed i offered with total honesty
i know i have talent actually i was one
heck of a good artist when i was younger
when i painted i was in heaven
i lost track of time when i was in the
studio painting i would get lost in the
canvas it was almost as if i transcended
time and moved into another dimension
john this is the power of concentrating
your mind on a pursuit that you love
maybe your dharma is to brighten the
world with lovely scenes at least start
spending a little time painting every
day
how about applying this philosophy to
things less esoteric than changing my
life let's say one of my aims was to
drop the spare tire i am carrying around
my waist where would i start
julian told me that the sages of
savannah had created a five-step method
to reach their objectives and fulfill
the purposes of their lives
the first step was to form a clear
mental picture of the outcome
if this was to lose weight every morning
just after i woke up i was to envision
myself as a lean fit person full of
vitality and boundless energy
step two was to get some positive
pressure on myself
pressure can inspire you to achieve
great ends
people generally achieve magnificent
things when they are forced to tap into
the wellspring of human potential that
lies within them
how can i create this positive pressure
on myself i asked now thinking about the
possibilities of applying this method to
everything from getting up earlier to
being a more patient and loving father
one of the best is the public pledge
tell everyone you know you will lose the
excess weight or whatever your goal
might be
once you make your goal known to the
world
there will instantly be pressure on you
to work towards its fulfillment since no
one likes to look like a failure
when you train your mind to associate
pleasure with good habits and punishment
with bad ones your weaknesses will
quickly fall by the wayside
you said there were five steps to follow
to make my desires come true i said
impatiently what are the remaining three
yes john the third step is a simple one
never set a goal without attaching a
timeline to it
to breathe life into a goal you must
have a precise deadline
remember that a goal that is not
committed to paper is no goal at all
go out and buy a journal a cheap coil
notepad will do
call this your dream book and fill it
with all your desires objectives and
dreams
get to know yourself and what you are
all about
don't i already know myself
most people don't
the chinese define image in these terms
there are three mirrors that form a
person's reflection
the first is how you see yourself
the second is how others see you
and the third mirror reflects the truth
know yourself john
know the truth
divide your dream book into separate
sections for goals relating to the
different areas of your life
for example you might have sections for
your physical fitness goals your
financial goals
your personal empowerment goals your
relationship and social goals and
perhaps most importantly your spiritual
goals
[Music]
hey that sounds like fun i've never
thought about doing something as
creative as that for myself i said
another particularly effective technique
is to fill your dream book with pictures
of the things you desire and images of
people who have cultivated the abilities
talents and qualities that you hope to
emulate
if you want to lose weight and be in
outstanding physical shape paste a
picture of a marathon runner or an elite
athlete in your dream book
if you want to be the world's finest
husband clip out a picture of someone
who represents this perhaps your father
and put it in your journal in the
relationship section
then review this book daily even for a
few minutes
make it your friend the results will
startle you
my wife would love to have a dream book
she'd probably fill it with pictures of
me without my notorious belly
it's really not that big julian
suggested in a consoling tone
then why does jenny call me mr donut i
said breaking into a bright smile
julian started to laugh i had to follow
soon the two of us were howling on the
floor
i guess if you can't laugh at yourself
who can you laugh at i said still
giggling
very true my friend
when i was chained to my former
lifestyle one of the main problems was
that i took life far too seriously
now i am much more playful and childlike
i enjoy all of life's gifts no matter
how small they are
but i have digressed
once you have formed a clear mental
picture of your outcome created a little
pressure behind it set a deadline and
committed it to paper the next step is
to apply what yogi roman called the
magic rule of 21.
the learned men and women of his world
believed that for a new behavior to
crystallize into a habit one had to
perform the new activity for 21 days in
a row
what's so special about 21 days
the only way to permanently install a
new habit is to direct so much energy
towards it that the old one slips away
like an unwelcome house guest
the installation is generally complete
in about 21 days the time it takes to
create a new neural pathway
saya wanted to start practicing the
heart of the rose technique to erase the
worry habit and live at a more peaceful
pace
do i have to do it at the same time
every day
good question the only reason to do
something is because you want to and
because you know it is the right thing
for you to do
my suggestion is that you try the heart
of the rose method at the same time
every day and in the same place every
day
there is tremendous power in a ritual
when you insert any activity into your
routine by doing it the same way at the
same time every day it quickly grows
into a habit
soon you will be performing the new
habit with the same ease that you feel
while brushing your teeth
and the final step for attaining goals
and advancing along the path of purpose
i wondered
the final step in the sages method is
one that is equally applicable as you
advance along the path of your life
the sages of savannah truly believed
that a day without laughter or a day
without love was a day without life
never forget the importance of living
with unbridled exhilaration
never neglect to see the exquisite
beauty in all living things remain
spirited joyful and curious
stay focused on your life work and on
giving selfless service to others
the universe will take care of
everything else this is one of nature's
truest laws
is that it
i still have much wisdom to share with
you
are you tired
not in the least actually i feel pretty
pumped up you're quite the motivator
julian have you ever thought about an
infomercial i asked mischievously
i don't understand he replied gently
never mind just one of my feeble
attempts at humor
okay
before we move along with yogi ramen's
fable there was one last point about
reaching goals and your dreams that i
would like to impress on you go for it
there is one word which the sages spoke
of in almost reverential terms
this simple word seemed to carry a depth
of meaning for them and it peppered
their daily talk
the word i am speaking of is passion and
it is a word you must constantly keep at
the forefront of your mind a burning
sense of passion is the most potent fuel
for your dreams
here in our society we have lost our
passion we do not do things because we
love to do them
we do things because we feel we have to
do them this is a formula for misery
reclaim the joy of waking up every
morning full of energy and exhilaration
breathe the fire of passion into all
that you do
you will quickly reap great material as
well as spiritual rewards you make it
sound so easy
it is from tonight onwards take complete
control of your life decide once and for
all to be the master of your fate
discover your calling and you will start
to experience the ecstasy of an inspired
life
finally always remember that what lies
behind you
and what lies in front of you is nothing
when compared to what lies within you
thanks julian i really needed to hear
this
i never realized all that was lacking in
my life until tonight
things are going to change
i promise you
i'm grateful for this
you're welcome my friend
i'm simply fulfilling my purpose
the ancient art of self-leadership
time is passing quickly said julian
before pouring himself another cup of
tea
the morning will soon be upon us do you
want me to continue or have you had
enough for one night
please continue julian i have all the
time in the world
the kids are sleeping at their
grandparents house tonight and jenny
won't be up for hours
sensing my sincerity he continued with
the symbolic fable that yogi ramen had
offered him to illustrate his wisdom
you will recall that as the fable
continues the door of the lighthouse
slowly opens and out walks a nine foot
tall 900 pound japanese sumo wrestler
sounds like a bad godzilla movie
i used to love those when i was a kid
julian said
me too but don't let me distract you
the sumo wrestler represents a very
important element in the life-changing
system of the sages of savannah
yogi ramen told me that many centuries
ago in the east the great teachers
developed and refined a philosophy
called kaizen
this japanese word means constant and
never-ending improvement and it's the
personal trademark of every man and
woman who is living a soaring fully
awakened existence
how did the concept of kaizen enrich the
lives of the sages i asked
if you really want to improve your outer
relationships or your finances you must
first improve your inner world the most
effective way to do this is through the
practice of continuous self-improvement
julian i hope you don't mind me saying
it but all this talk about one's inner
world sounds more than a little esoteric
to me i'm having a little difficulty
with this notion of kaizen and improving
my inner world what exactly are we
talking about here
julian was agile in his response
when i speak of improving your inner
world i am simply speaking of
self-improvement and personal expansion
and it is the best thing you can do for
yourself
taking the time to master your mind to
care for your body and to nourish your
soul will put you in the position to
develop more richness and vitality in
your life
it is as epic titus said so many years
ago
no man is free who is not a master of
himself
i nodded in full agreement this was the
first time i had given any serious
thought to the importance of improving
myself
i really could use the added energy in
good health that exercising would surely
bring
ridding myself of my nasty temper and my
habit of interrupting others might do
wonders for my relationship with my wife
and kids and erasing my worry habit
would give me the peace of mind and deep
happiness i had been searching for
the more i thought about it the more
potential improvements i saw
julian spoke of the importance of
building strength of character
developing mental toughness and living
with courage
he told me that these three attributes
would lead not only to a virtuous life
but a life filled with achievement
satisfaction and inner peace
courage was a quality everyone could
cultivate and one that would pay huge
dividends over the long run
what does courage have to do with
self-leadership and personal development
i wondered aloud
courage allows you to do whatever you
want to do because you know it is right
ultimately the degree of courage you
live with determines the amount of
fulfillment you receive
and those who master themselves have an
abundance of courage
okay i'm starting to understand the
power for working on myself
where do i start
julian returned to his conversation with
yogi ramen high atop the mountains on
what he remembered as a remarkably
starry and gloriously beautiful night
the more i listened to yogi ramen and
the more i reflected on the pain and
suffering of my former world the more i
welcome the philosophy of kaizen
constant and never-ending enrichment of
the mind body and soul into my new life
julian asserted
why am i hearing so much about the mind
body and soul these days it seems i
can't even turn on the tube without
someone making mention of it
this is the trilogy of our human
endowments
to improve our mind without the
cultivation of your physical gifts would
be a very hollow victory
elevating your mind and body to their
highest level without nurturing your
soul would leave you feeling very empty
and unfulfilled
but when you dedicate your energies to
unlocking the full potential of all
three of your human endowments you will
taste the divine ecstasy of an
enlightened life
you've got me pretty excited pal
and as to your question about where to
start i promise that i will give you a
number of ancient yet powerful
techniques in a few moments
but first i must share a practical
illustration with you
get into push-up position
good grief julian's become a drill
sergeant i silently thought
being curious and wishing to keep my cup
empty i complied
now do as many push-ups as you can
possibly do
don't stop until you truly are certain
that you cannot do any more
i struggled with the exercise
the first 15 push-ups were pure agony
at 23 push-ups i gave up
no more julian this is killing me
the only lesson i'm going to learn from
this is what to do for a heart attack
do 10 more then you can rest commanded
julian
you've got to be kidding
but i continued
one
two
five eight
and finally ten
i lay on the floor in total exhaustion
what could anyone possibly learn from an
experience like this i asked
breathlessly
you told me after you had done 23 that
you couldn't do anymore
you told me that this was your absolute
limit
yet when i challenged you to do more you
responded with another 10 push-ups
you had more inside you and when you
reached for your resources you received
more
yogi ramen explained a fundamental truth
to me
the only limits on your life are those
that you set yourself
when you push beyond your limits just as
you did in this demonstration you unlock
mental and physical reserves that you
never thought you had
julian since he was on a roll
you practice the art of kaizen by
pushing yourself daily work hard to
improve your mind and your body
nourish your spirit
do the things you fear
be the person you dream of being
julian continued his passionate
discourse
identify the things that are holding you
back
take the time to reflect on what might
be keeping you from the life you really
want
and no deep down you can have
once you have identified what your
weaknesses are the next step is to face
them head on and attack your fears
this might be the first taste of real
freedom that you have experienced in
years
fear is nothing more than a mental
monster you have created a negative
stream of consciousness
you mean all my fears are nothing more
than imaginary little gremlins that have
crept into my mind over the years
exactly john every time they have
prevented you from taking some action
you have added fuel to their fire but
when you conquer your fears you conquer
your life
i need an example study a baby she has
no limits her mind is a lush landscape
of potential and possibility
properly cultivated it will lead her to
greatness
filled with negativity it will lead her
to mediocrity at best
a baby could be trained to view a
glorious sunny day as depressing
a child could be trained to see a puppy
as a vicious animal
an adult could be trained to see a drug
as a pleasant vehicle for release
it's all a matter of conditioning isn't
it
sure
the same holds true for fear
fear is a conditioned response a
life-sucking habit that can easily
consume your energy creativity and
spirit if you are not careful
when fear rears its ugly head beat it
down quickly
the best way you can do this is to do
the thing you fear
when you erase fear from your mind you
start to look younger and your health
becomes more vibrant
ah the old mind body connection i
replied hoping to mask my ignorance
yes the sages of the east have known
about it for over 5 000 years hardly new
age he said with a broad grin
truly enlightened people are prepared to
put off short-term pleasure for the sake
of long-term fulfillment
they resolve to live by the wisdom of
kaizen improving every aspect of
themselves ceaselessly and continuously
with time things that were once
difficult become easy
fears that once prevented them from all
the happiness health and prosperity they
deserved fall to the wayside like
stickmen toppled by a hurricane
so you're suggesting that i must change
myself before i change my life
yes it's like that old story my favorite
professor told me when i was in law
school
one night a father was relaxing with his
newspaper after a long day at the office
his son who wanted to play kept on
pestering him
finally fed up the father ripped out a
picture of the globe that was in the
newspaper and tore it into a hundred
tiny pieces
here son go and try to put this back
together he said
to his amazement his son returned after
only one minute with the globe perfectly
back together
when the startled father asked him how
he achieved this feat the son smiled and
gently replied
dad on the other side of the globe there
was a picture of a person and once i got
the person together
the world was okay
that's a great story
you see john the wisest people i have
ever met
from the sages of savannah to my
professors at harvard law school all
seem to know the key formula for
happiness
exactly how does one go about building
courage
it's the same as the story once you get
yourself together your world will be
okay
but you must spend some time daily
working on yourself even if for only 10
or 15 minutes
and what does the nine foot tall 900
pound japanese sumo wrestler symbolize
in yogi ramen's fable
our hefty friend will be your constant
reminder of the power of kaizen
[Music]
in just a few hours julian had revealed
the most powerful information that i had
ever heard in my lifetime
now i had been exposed to the ageless
principle of self-mastery kaizen
how can i practice the art of kaizen
i will give you 10 ancient yet supremely
effective rituals that will lead you far
along the path of personal mastery if
you apply them on a daily basis with
faith in their utility you will observe
remarkable results in just one month
from today
yogi ramen offered the ten rituals to me
with great faith in what he termed their
exquisiteness
the quid pro quo is that you must set
aside at least one hour a day for thirty
consecutive days to practice the
strategies
this investment in yourself is all it
takes
one hour a day for 30 days is all it
takes
it's the magic formula i was always
searching for
having said this you must be disciplined
and apply the strategies which make up
the formula daily with utter conviction
in their value
this is not a quick fix type deal
once you are in you are in it for the
long term
what do you mean
spending one hour a day tending to
yourself will surely give you dramatic
results in 30 days provided you do the
right things the key is that you must
keep on practicing them every day if you
want to keep on seeing the results
fair enough i agreed julian clearly had
unlocked a wellspring of personal
vitality and inner serenity in his own
life actually his transformation from a
sickly old litigator to a radiant
energetic philosopher was nothing less
than miraculous
maybe i too could undergo a mantle-like
transformation
it was surely worth a
try that night sitting on the floor of
my cluttered living room i learned what
julian called the 10 rituals of radiant
living
the first strategy was known to the
sages as the ritual of solitude this
involves nothing more than ensuring that
your daily schedule include a mandatory
period of peace
just what is a period of peace
it is a period of time as little as 15
minutes or as much as 50
wherein you explore the healing power of
silence and come to know who you really
are
its purpose is self renewal and this is
accomplished by spending time alone
immersed in the beautiful blanket of
silence
solitude and quiet connect you to your
creative source and release the
limitless intelligence of the universe
you will even sleep better and enjoy a
renewed feeling of balance in your
day-to-day activities
where should i go for this period of
peace
theoretically you could do it anywhere
from your bedroom to your office the key
is to find a place of true quiet and
beauty
how does beauty fit into the equation
beautiful images sue the ruffled soul
julian observed with the deep sigh
a bouquet of roses or a simple solitary
daffodil will have a highly salutary
effect on your senses and relax you to
no end
ideally you should savor such beauty in
a space that will serve as a sanctuary
of the self
what's that
basically it is a place that will become
your secret form for mental and
spiritual expansion
this might be a spare room in your house
or simply a peaceful corner of a small
apartment
the point is to reserve a spot for your
renewal activities a place that sits
there quietly awaiting your arrival
i love the sound of that i think having
a silent place to go to when i come home
from work would make a world of
difference
that brings up another important point
the ritual of solitude works best when
you practice it at the same time every
day
by practicing it at the same time every
day a daily dose of silence will soon
become a habit that you will never
neglect
anything else
yes if at all possible commune with
nature daily a quick walk through the
woods or even a few minutes spent
cultivating your tomato garden in the
backyard will reconnect you to the
wellspring of calm that may now be
dormant within you being with nature
also allows you to tune into the
infinite wisdom of your highest self
this self knowledge will move you into
the uncharted dimensions of your
personal power
never forget this julian advised his
voice rising with passion
has this ritual worked well for you
julian
absolutely
someday i spend hours in quiet
contemplation
on other days i spend only 10 minutes
the result is more or less the same
a deep sense of inner harmony and an
abundance of physical energy
which brings me to the second ritual
this is the ritual of physicality
sounds interesting what's it all about
the ritual of physicality is based on
the principle that says as you care for
the body so you care for the mind
as you train your body so you train your
mind
take some time every single day to
nourish the temple of your body through
vigorous exercise
get your blood circulating and your body
moving did you know that there are 168
hours in a week
no not really
it's true
at least five of those hours should be
invested in some form of physical
activity
the sages of savannah practiced the
ancient discipline of yoga to awaken
their physical potential and live a
strong dynamic existence
it was an extraordinary sight to see
these marvelous physical specimens who
would manage to age proof their lives
standing on their heads in the center of
their village
did the sages do anything else to care
for their bodies
yogi ramen and his brothers and sisters
also believed that vigorous walking in
natural surroundings worked wonders for
relieving fatigue and restoring the body
to its natural state of vibrancy
i really think it didn't matter too much
to them what they did
so long as they moved their bodies and
got the fresh air of their breathtaking
surroundings flowing through their lungs
what does breathing fresh air have to do
with anything i'll answer your question
with one of yogi ramen's favorite
sayings to breathe properly is to live
properly
quite early on in savannah the sages
taught me that the fastest way to double
or even triple the amount of energy i
had was to learn the art of effective
breathing
their philosophy was simple
take in more oxygen through efficient
breathing and you liberate your energy
reserves along with your natural state
of vitality
okay so where do i start
it's actually pretty easy two or three
times a day take a minute or two to
think about breathing more deeply and
effectively your belly should move out
slightly this indicates that you are
breathing from the abdomen which is good
a trick that yogi ramen taught me was to
cup my hands over my stomach if they
moved out as i inhaled my breathing
technique was proper
very interesting
if you like that then you'll love the
third ritual of radiant living said
julian which is
the ritual of live nourishment
yogi ramen put it this way
as you nourish your body so you nourish
your mind
i assume then that you changed your diet
radically live foods are the answer
live foods are those which are created
through the natural interaction of the
sun air soil and water what i'm talking
about here is a vegetarian diet fill
your plate with fresh vegetables fruit
and grains and you might just live
forever
is that possible
most of the sages were well over 100 and
they showed no signs of slowing down
but is this type of diet healthy
this is the diet that nature intended it
is alive vital and supremely healthy the
sages have lived by this diet for many
thousands of years
if you like meat you can certainly keep
eating it just remember that you are
ingesting dead food
if you can cut back on the amount of red
meat that you eat it is really hard to
digest and since your digestive system
is one of the body's most energy
consuming processes valuable energy
reserves are needlessly depleted by this
food stuff
do you see what i'm getting at
just compare how you feel after eating a
steak with your energy levels after
you've had a salad
if you don't want to become a strict
vegetarian at least start having a salad
with every meal and fruit for dessert
even this will make a huge difference in
the quality of your physical life
try it for about a month and judge the
results for yourself you will feel
phenomenal
okay
if it's good enough for the sages it's
good enough for me
i promise you i will give it a shot
if i have sold you on the ritual of live
nourishment i think you will love the
fourth one
the student is still holding his empty
cup
the fourth ritual is known as the ritual
of abundant knowledge it centers around
the whole notion of lifelong learning
and expanding your knowledge base for
the good of yourself and all those
around you
read regularly
reading for 30 minutes a day will do
wonders for you but i must caution you
do not read just anything
make it something that will improve both
you and the quality of your life
what did the sages read
they spent many of their waking moments
reading and re-reading the ancient
teachings of their ancestors
they devoured this philosophical
literature it was in savannah that i
really learned the power of the book and
the principle that a book is the best
friend of the wise
to truly get the best out of a great
book you must study it not just read it
the sages would read many of the books
of wisdom in their vast library 10 or 15
times
they treated great books as scriptures
holy documents of divine origin
wow is reading really that important
30 minutes a day will make a delightful
difference in your life because you will
quickly start to see the vast reserves
of knowledge available for your use
read the right books learn how those who
have preceded you have handled the
challenges you are currently facing
what exactly are the right books any
titles you could recommend to an eager
young beaver i said flashing abroad grin
sure
you will thrive on the biography of the
great american benjamin franklin
i think you will also find much growth
impetus from mahatma gandhi's
autobiography entitled the story of my
experiments with truth
i also suggest that you read siddhartha
by herman hess the highly practical
philosophy of marcus aurelius and some
of the work of seneca
you might even read think and grow rich
by napoleon hill i read it last week and
i thought it was very profound
thinking grow rich i exclaimed but i
thought you left all that behind you i'm
really sick and tired of all the make
money fast manuals that are being
peddled out there by snake oil salesmen
preying on the week easy big fella i
couldn't agree with you more often
julian with all the warmth and patience
of a wise loving grandfather
that little book is not about making a
lot of money it's about making a lot of
life
think and grow rich is about abundance
including spiritual abundance and how to
attract all that is good into your life
you might do well to read it but i will
not press the point
sorry julian i guess my temper gets the
better of me sometimes i offered
apologetically
one more thing i need to improve
i really am grateful for all that you
are sharing with me
no problem my point is simply read and
keep reading do you want to know
something else interesting
what
books simply help you to see what is
already within yourself that's what
enlightenment is all about
after all my journeying and exploring i
found that i have actually come full
circle back to the point from which i
started as a young boy
but now i know myself
and all that i am and can be
okay what's the fifth ritual of radiant
living
it is the ritual of personal reflection
you see we all have many sleeping
talents inside of us
by taking the time to get to know them
we kindle them
however silent contemplation will
deliver even more than this
this practice will make you stronger
more at ease with yourself and wiser
i'm still a little fuzzy on the concept
julian
every night the sages would retire to
the sanctuary of their huts covered by
fragrant rose petals and sit in deep
contemplation
yogi ramen would actually take a written
inventory of his day
what kinds of things would he write down
i asked
first he would list all of his
activities from the personal care
activities of his morning to his
interactions with the other sages
interestingly he would also write down
the thoughts he had run through his mind
during that particular day
isn't that hard to do i can hardly
remember what i thought five minutes ago
let alone 12 hours ago
take the time to think
get into the regular habit of personal
introspection
once yogi roman had listed all that he
had done and all that he had thought in
one column he would then do an
assessment in another column
as he was confronted by his activities
and thoughts in the written form he
asked himself whether they were positive
in nature
if they were he resolved to continue
giving his precious energy to them
and if they were negative
then he would come up with a clear
course of action to get rid of them
i think an example might help me
can it be personal julian asked
sure i'd love to know some of your
innermost thoughts i suggested
actually i was thinking about yours
we both started to giggle like a couple
of kids in a schoolyard
oh all right you always did get your own
way
okay let's go through just a few of the
things that you did today
write them down on that piece of paper
on the coffee table julian instructed
i started to realize that something
important was about to happen this was
the first time in years that i had
actually taken the time to do nothing
but reflect on the things i was doing
and the thoughts i was thinking
where do i start i asked
start with what you did this morning and
progressed through your day
just hit a few of the highlights
fine
i woke up at 6 30 to the sound of my
electric rooster i joked
get serious and keep going julian
replied firmly
okay then i showered and shaved gobbled
down a waffle and rushed off to work
and what about your family
they were all asleep
anyway once i got to the office i
noticed that my 7 30 appointment had
been waiting there since seven and boy
was he furious
what was your response
i fought back what was i supposed to do
let him push me around
hmm
okay then what happened
well things went from bad to worse the
courthouse called and told me the judge
wildebeest needed to see me in his
chambers and if i wasn't there within 10
minutes heads would roll
i rushed down to the courthouse and had
another argument with one of the clerks
by the time i got back to the office
there were 27 phone messages waiting for
me all marked urgent need i go on
please do
well on my way home jenny called me in
the car and asked me to stop by her
mother's house and pick up some of those
amazing pies my
is famous for
problem was that when i took that exit i
found myself in the middle of a gridlock
so there i was in the middle of rush
hour traffic in 95 degree heat shaking
with stress and feeling that even more
time was slipping away
how did you respond
i cursed the traffic i said with
complete honesty i was actually shouting
out loud inside my car
maybe we should stop there
just take a second and look at your day
obviously in retrospect there are at
least a few things that you would do
differently if you had the chance
wouldn't you
well first in a perfect world i would
get up earlier
i'd like to have a little peace in the
morning and ease myself into the day the
heart of the rose technique sounds like
it would be fun
also i really would like to have the
family around the breakfast table
even if only for a bowl of cereal
it would give me a better sense of
balance i always seem to feel that i
never spend enough time with jenny and
the kids
but it is a perfect world and you have a
perfect life you do have the power to
control your day you do have the power
to live your dreams julian observed his
voice rising
i am realizing this i really am starting
to feel that i can change
great continue reflecting on your day he
instructed
well i wish i hadn't yelled at my client
i wish i hadn't argued with the court
clerk and i wish i hadn't screamed at
the traffic
i think you now see the power of the
ritual of personal reflection julian
said
by looking at what you are doing how you
are spending your day and the thoughts
you are thinking you give yourself a
benchmark for measuring improvement
the only way to improve tomorrow is to
know what you did wrong today
lots to think about julian lot to think
about i offered reflectively
how about thinking about the sixth
ritual for radiant living the ritual of
early awakening
oh i think i know what's coming
one of the best pieces of advice i
learned in that far off oasis of
savannah was to rise with the sun and to
start the day off well
most of us sleep far more than we need
to
the average person can get by on six
hours and remain perfectly healthy and
alert
getting up with the sun sounds extreme
actually it isn't there are few things
more natural than rising with the glory
of the first rays of a new day
the sages believed that sunshine was a
gift from heaven and while they were
careful not to overexpose themselves
they regularly had sun baths and often
could be seen dancing playfully in the
early morning sunshine
i firmly believe that this was another
key to their extraordinary longevity
hmm how do i build this ritual into my
routine
here are a couple of quick tips
first never forget that it is the
quality and not the quantity of sleep
that is important
it is better to have six hours of
uninterrupted deep sleep than even 10
hours of disturbed sleep for example
yogi ramen would never eat after 8 pm he
said that the digestive activity it
induced would reduce the quality of his
sleep
another example was the sage's habit of
meditating to the soft sounds of their
harp immediately before heading off to
sleep what was the reason behind this
the 10-minute period before you sleep
and the 10-minute period after you wake
up are profoundly influential on your
subconscious mind
by determining the thoughts that go in
you are also determining precisely what
will come out
so before you go to sleep do not watch
the news or argue with anyone or even go
over the day's events in your mind's eye
relax
[Music]
drink a cup of herbal tea if you like
listen to some soft classical music and
prepare yourself to drift into a rich
renewing slumber
it makes sense the better the sleep the
less i will need exactly and remember
the ancient rule of 21
if you do anything for 21 days in a row
it will be installed as a habit
so stay with the early rising routine
for about three weeks by then it will be
a part of your life
within short order you will be able to
rise at 5 30 a.m or even 5 a.m with ease
ready to savor the splendor of another
great day
okay so let's say that i am getting up
every day at 5 30. what do i do
as i've suggested the thoughts you think
and the actions you take in the first 10
minutes after you wake up have a market
effect on the rest of your day
think positive thoughts give a prayer
thanks for all you have the sages would
actually make themselves laugh whether
they felt like it or not just to get the
happiness juices flowing early in the
morning
julian i am trying very hard to keep my
cup empty and i think you will agree
that i've done pretty well for a novice
but that sounds really odd even for a
band of monks living high in the
himalayas
but it's not
take a guess how many times the average
four-year-old laughs in a day
who knows
i do three hundred now guess how many
times the average adult in our society
laughs in the course of a day
50 i tried
try 15 said julian smiling in
satisfaction you see my point laughter
is medicine for the soul even if you
don't feel like it look in the mirror
and laugh for a couple of minutes you
can't help but feel fantastic
every day will then be an exquisitely
rewarding one
what do you do to start your day off on
a positive footing
actually i have developed quite a
sophisticated morning routine which
includes everything from the heart of
the rose to drinking a couple of glasses
of freshly squeezed fruit juice but
there is one strategy in particular
which i would like to share with you
sounds important
it is
shortly after you have awakened go into
your sanctuary of silence get still and
focused
then ask yourself this question
what would i do today if this day was my
last
mentally list all the things you would
do the people you would call and the
moments you would savor when you live
every day as if it was your last your
life will take on a magical quality
and this brings me to the seventh of the
rituals of radiant living
the ritual of music
never forget the power of music
spend a little time with it every day
even if it is listening to a soft piece
on a cassette while you drive to work
when you feel down or weary play some
music it is one of the finest motivators
i know of
aside from yourself i exclaimed
sincerely
just listening to you makes me feel
great
you really have changed julian and not
just on the outside you really do seem
to be at peace with yourself
you have touched me tonight
hey there's more shadow julian with his
fist in the air let's keep going
i wouldn't have it any other way
okay
the eighth ritual is the ritual of the
spoken word the sages had a series of
mantras which they would recite morning
noon and night
they told me that this practice was
immensely effective in keeping them
focused strong and happy
what's a mantra i asked
a mantra is nothing more than a
collection of words strung together to
create a positive effect
in sanskrit man means mind and tra means
freeing so a mantra is a phrase which is
designed to free the mind
and believe me john mantra has
accomplished this objective in a very
powerful way
so mantras are spoken
they don't have to be written
affirmations also are very effective but
i have found that repeating a mantra
aloud has a wonderful effect on my
spirit when i need to feel motivated i
might repeat i am inspired disciplined
and energized out loud two or three
hundred times
to maintain the supreme sense of
self-confidence i have cultivated i
might repeat i am strong able and calm
i even use mantras to keep me youthful
and vital julian admitted
which leads us to the ninth ritual of
radiant living quite nicely
this is the ritual of congruent
character
this ritual requires you to take daily
incremental action to build your
character
perhaps yogi ramen articulated the
formula best when he stated you sow a
thought you reap an action reap in
action you sow a habit
so a habit you reap a character
so a character you reap your destiny
what kinds of things should i do to
build my character
anything that cultivates your virtues
before you ask me what i mean by virtues
let me clarify the concept
the wise people of the himalayas believe
strongly that a virtuous life was a
meaningful life so they governed all
their actions by a series of timeless
principles
but i thought you said they governed
their lives by their purpose
yes this is quite so but their life's
calling included living in a manner
congruent to these principles
they are simply stated industry
compassion humility
patience honesty and courage
when all your actions are congruent and
aligned with these principles you will
feel a deep sense of inner harmony and
peace
this is also when your life will move
from the ordinary into the realm of the
extraordinary and you will begin to
sense the sacredness of your being it is
the first step to lifelong enlightenment
have you tasted this experience i asked
i have and i believe you will too
do the right things act in a way that is
congruent with your true character act
with integrity
be guided by your heart the rest will
take care of itself
you are never alone you know
and the final ritual
this is the all-important ritual of
simplicity this ritual requires you to
live a simple life
as yogi ramen said one must never live
in the thick of thin things
focus only on your priorities those
activities which are truly meaningful
your life will be uncluttered rewarding
and exceptionally peaceful this i
promise you
but earlier you told me that happiness
comes from achievement now you are
telling me to reduce my needs and be
content with less
isn't that a paradox
excellent point john it might seem like
a contradiction but it isn't
lifelong happiness does come through
striving to realize your dreams
the key is not to make your happiness
contingent on finding that elusive pot
of gold at the end of the rainbow
for example even though i was a
millionaire many times over i was so
money driven that i couldn't enjoy all
that i had
you know there came a time when all i
could eat was bread and water julian
said growing very quiet and pensive
are you serious i always thought that
you ate at the best restaurants with all
those celebrity friends of yours
that was in the early days
not many people know about this but the
burden of my out of control lifestyle
gave me a bleeding ulcer
julian caught himself but i'm not one to
live in the past it was another one of
life's great lessons to transcend pain i
had to first experience it
i wouldn't be where i am today without
it he said stoically
any ideas on what i should do to bring
the ritual of simplicity into my life i
asked
there are so many things you can do
stop picking up the phone every time it
rings
stop wasting time reading junk mail
stop eating out three times a week
give up your golf club membership and
spend more time with your kids
spend a day a week without your watch
watch the sun rise every few days sell
your cellular phone and dump your pager
need i continue julian asked
rhetorically
i get the point but sell the cell phone
i asked anxiously feeling as a baby
might at the doctor's suggestion that
his umbilical cord should be cut
like i've said my duty is to share the
wisdom i've learned through my journey
with you you need not apply every
strategy to make your life work try the
techniques and use those that feel right
to you
after julian had explained the ten
rituals for radiant living he paused
i know that you want me to keep on going
so i will
perhaps this is a good time to get a
little deeper
what i've taught you up to now has been
immensely practical
but you must know something of the
underlying spiritual current which flows
through the principles i've outlined
okay let's hear the spiritual stuff i
said energetically unaware that it was
nearly 2 30 in the morning
within you lies the sun
the moon the sky and all the wonders of
this universe
the intelligence that created these
wonders is the same force that created
you
all things around you come from the same
source
we are all
one i'm not sure i follow you
every being on this earth every object
on this earth has a soul
all souls flow into one this is the soul
of the universe
you see john when you nourish your own
mind and your own spirit you are really
feeding the soul of the universe
when you improve yourself you are
improving the lives of all those around
you
and when you have the courage to advance
confidently in the direction of your
dreams you begin to draw upon the power
of the universe
julian i know you mean well
but what happens if i fail
failure is not having the courage to try
nothing more and nothing less the only
thing standing between most people and
their dreams is the fear of failure yet
failure is essential to success in any
endeavor
never fear failure failure is your
friend
[Music]
the power of discipline
julian continued to use yogi ramen's
mystical fable as the cornerstone for
the wisdom he was sharing with me
you will recall that our friend the sumo
wrestler was stark naked except for the
pink wire cable covering his private
parts i interjected gamely
right applauded julian the pink wire
cable will serve to remind you of the
power of self-control and discipline in
building a richer happier and more
enlightened life
my teachers in savannah taught me that
the virtue of discipline was like a wire
cable have you ever really taken the
time to study a wire cable john
it hasn't been high on my priority list
i confessed with a quick grin
we'll have a look at one some time you
will see that it consists of many thin
tiny wires placed one on top of the
other alone each one is flimsy and weak
but together their sum is much greater
than their constituent parts and the
cable becomes tougher than iron
self-control and willpower are similar
to this
to build a wheel of iron it is essential
to take small tiny acts in tribute to
the virtue of personal discipline
performed the little acts pile one on
top of another to eventually produce an
abundance of inner strength
self-discipline will provide you with
the mental reserves required to
persevere when life throws you one of
its little curves
i must also alert you to the fact that
the lack of willpower is a mental
disease julian added surprisingly
willpower allows you to do what you said
you would do when you said you would do
it it is willpower that offers you the
inner power to keep your commitments to
others and perhaps even more importantly
to yourself
is it really that important
most certainly my friend it is the
essential virtue of every person who has
created a life rich with passion
possibility and peace
julian then reached into his robe and
pulled out a shiny silver locket the
kind you might see in a museum exhibit
on ancient egypt
you shouldn't have i joked
the sages of savannah gave this gift to
me on my last evening with them
it was a joyous loving celebration
between members of a family who had
lived life to the fullest
it was one of the greatest and one of
the saddest nights of my life
i left part of myself high in the
himalayas that evening julian said his
voice growing soft
what are the words engraved on the
locket
here i'll read them to you
never forget them john they have really
helped me when times got tough
through the steel of discipline you will
forge a character rich with courage and
peace
through the virtue of will you are
destined to rise to life's highest ideal
and live within a heavenly mansion
filled with all that is good
joyful and vital
without them you are lost like a mariner
without a compass
one who eventually sinks with his ship
julian added
building self-control and discipline
into your life will also bring you a
tremendous sense of freedom
this alone will change things
julian then noted the many practical
benefits that the cultivation of
discipline would bring
believe it or not developing the power
of your will can erase the worry habit
keep you healthy and give you far more
energy than you have ever had
you see john self control is really
nothing more than mind control
will is the king of mental powers
when you master your mind you master
your life mental mastery starts with
being able to control every thought that
you think
when you have developed the ability to
discard all weak thoughts and focus only
on those that are positive and good
positive and good actions will follow
soon you will start attracting all that
is positive and good into your life
here's an example let's say one of your
personal development goals is to get up
every morning at six am and go for a run
let's pretend it is now the middle of
winter and your alarm wakes you from a
deep restful sleep
your first impulse is to hit the snooze
button and return to your slumber
perhaps you will live up to your
exercise resolution tomorrow
this pattern continues for a few days
until you decide that you are too old to
change your ways and the physical
fitness goal was too unrealistic
you know me too well i offered sincerely
now let's consider an alternative
scenario
it is still the dead of winter the alarm
goes off and you start to think of
staying in bed but instead of being a
slave to your habits you challenge them
with more powerful thoughts
you start to picture in your mind's eye
how you will look feel and act when you
are in peak physical shape
you focus on all that you can accomplish
with the increased energy a regular
exercise program will bring
no more nights spent in front of the
television because you are too tired to
do anything else after your long day in
court your days are filled with vitality
enthusiasm and meaning
but say i do this and i still feel like
going back to sleep rather than going
running
if you continue to wage war against the
weaker thoughts that might have silently
crept into the palace of your mind over
the years eventually they will see that
they are unwanted and leave like
visitors who know that they are not
welcome
you mean to tell me the thoughts are
physical things
yes and they are fully in your control
it is just as easy to think positive
thoughts as it is to think negative ones
so if i want to have the inner strength
to get up earlier eat less read more
worry less be more patient or be more
loving all i have to do is exert my will
to cleanse my thoughts
when you control your thoughts you
control your mind when you control your
mind you control your life
and once you reach the stage of being in
total control of your life you become
the master of your destiny
i needed to hear this
through the course of this strange yet
inspiring evening i had gone from being
a skeptical litigator carefully studying
a hotshot lawyer turned yogi to a
believer whose eyes had been opened for
the first time in many years
i wish jenny could hear all this
actually
i wish my kids could hear this wisdom
too
i knew it would affect them as it had me
i'd always planned on being a better
family man and living more fully but i
always found that i was too busy putting
out all those brush fires of life that
seemed so pressing
it seemed like yesterday that i was a
young law student full of energy and
enthusiasm
i dreamed of becoming a political leader
or even a supreme court judge back then
but as time went by i settled into a
routine
i think it was at that moment with
julian sitting next to me on my living
room floor on that sticky july night
that i changed
the japanese called satori meaning
instant awakening and that's exactly
what it was
i resolved to fulfill my dreams and make
my life far more than it had ever been
that was my first taste of real freedom
the freedom that comes when you decide
once and for all to take charge of your
life and all its constituent elements
i will give you a formula for developing
willpower said julian who had no idea of
the inner transformation i had just
experienced
wisdom without proper tools for its
application is no wisdom at all
[Music]
he continued
every day while you are walking to work
i would like you to repeat a few simple
words
yogi ramen told me that by its
repetition i would develop self-control
and an indomitable will within a short
period of time
okay i'm all ears
this is the mantra i suggest you repeat
at least 30 times a day
i am more than i appear to be
all the world's strength and power rest
inside me
it will manifest profound changes in
your life for even quicker results blend
this mantra with the practice of
creative envisioning i spoke of earlier
startling results will surely come your
way you promised
that's it
i asked astonished by the apparent
simplicity of this formula
i can tap the full reserves of my
willpower through this simple exercise
repeating the mantra i gave you along
with the daily practice of seeing
yourself as you hope to be will give you
an enormous amount of support as you
create the disciplined principled life
that will connect you to your dreams
and you need not change your world in a
day
start off small
even training yourself to get up an hour
earlier and sticking to this wonderful
habit will boost your self-confidence
inspiring you to reach higher heights
the trick is to keep setting the mark
higher and raising your standards
continuously
this will release that magical quality
of momentum that will motivate you to
keep exploring your infinite potential
momentum is also the secret ingredient
to building self-discipline
it's a delightful process john it really
is
and the pink wire cable in yogi ramen's
magical fable will always remind you of
the power of your will
just as julian finished revealing his
thoughts on the subject of discipline i
noticed the first rays of the sun
peeking into the living room pushing
away the darkness like a child pushes
away an unwanted bed cover
this will be a great day i thought
the first day of the rest of my life
your most precious commodity
[Music]
you know what's funny about life julian
said
by the time most people figure out what
they really want and how to go about
attaining it it's usually too late
is that what the stopwatch and yogi
rumman's fable is all about
yes the naked 9 foot tall 900 pound sumo
wrestler with the pink wire cable
covering his private parts slips on a
shiny gold stopwatch that someone has
left in the beautiful garden julian
reminded me
and exactly what does the shiny gold
stopwatch represent
it is a symbol of her most precious
commodity
time
what about positive thinking and goal
setting and self-mastery
they all mean nothing without time
about six months after i made savannah
my temporary home one of the sages came
to my hut while i was studying
her name was divya
she was a stunningly beautiful woman
with jet black hair that fell below her
waist and in a very gentle and sweet
voice she informed me that she was the
youngest of all of the sages
she also said that she had come to me on
the instructions of yogi ramen
as the youngest of our community i've
been asked to bring you a gift it is
from all of us and we offer it as a
token of our respect for you one who has
traveled so far to learn our ways
what was the gift i asked impatiently
it was a miniature hourglass which had
been made from blown glass and a small
piece of sandalwood
seeing my expression vivia quickly told
me that each of the sages had received
one of these instruments as children
though we have no possessions and live
pure simple lives we respect time and
note its passing
these little hourglasses serve as daily
reminders of our mortality and the
importance of living full productive
days while advancing our purposes
these monks kept time
each and every one of them understood
the importance of time
they each had developed what i call a
time consciousness
time is the greatest leveler
whether we are privileged or
disadvantaged whether we live in texas
or tokyo we all have been allotted days
with only 24 hours
once i heard my father say it was the
busiest people who have time to spare
what do you make of that
busy productive people are highly
efficient with their time they must be
in order to survive
being an excellent time manager doesn't
mean that you must become a workaholic
on the contrary time mastery allows you
more time to do the things that are
truly meaningful to you time mastery
leads to life mastery guard your time
well remember it's a non-renewable
resource
let me give you an example julian
offered
let's say it's monday morning and your
schedule is overflowing with
appointments and meetings
let's say you took 15 minutes the night
before to plan your day or to be even
more effective let's say you took one
hour on your quiet sunday morning to
organize your entire week in your daily
planner you wrote out when you would
meet your clients when you would do
legal research and when you would return
phone calls
most importantly your personal social
and spiritual development goals for the
week also went into your agenda book
by anchoring all the most vital aspects
of your life into your daily schedule
you ensure that your week and your life
retain a sense of meaning and peace
surely you're not suggesting that i take
a break in the middle of my busy work
day to walk in the park or meditate
all i'm saying is plan your week and
manage your time creatively have the
discipline to focus your time around
your priorities
the most meaningful things in your life
should never be sacrificed to those that
are the least meaningful
i agree julian but i really don't have
the time to take breaks in the middle of
my day as it is i work most evenings
as i said this i felt my stomach
tingling at the mere thought of the
mountain of work i was facing
one of the great rules i learned from
that wise old sage is that eighty
percent of the results you achieve in
your life come from only twenty percent
of the activities that occupy your time
yogi ramen called it the ancient rule of
twenty
i'm not sure i follow you
okay let's go back to your busy monday
from morning until night you might spend
your time doing everything from drafting
legal pleadings to reading your youngest
child a bedtime story or playing chess
with your wife
agreed
agreed
but out of all of the hundreds of
activities you give your time to only
twenty percent will yield real lasting
results
only twenty percent of what you do will
have an influence on the quality of your
life
these are your high impact activities
for example 10 years from now do you
really think that all the time you spend
gossiping at the water cooler or
watching television would account for
anything
no
not really
right so i'm sure you will also agree
there are a number of activities that
will account for everything
you mean like time spent improving my
legal knowledge time spent enriching my
relationships with my clients and time
invested in becoming a more efficient
lawyer
yes and time spent nourishing your
relationship with jenny and the kids
time spent connecting with nature and
showing gratitude for all you are so
fortunate to have
time spent renewing your mind your body
and your spirit
direct all of your time to those
activities that count
enlightened people are priority driven
this is the secret of time mastery
wow yogi ramen taught you all that
i have become a student of life john
yogi ramon certainly was a wonderful and
inspiring teacher and i will never
forget him for that
but all of the lessons i have learned
from my varied experiences have now come
together like pieces of a big jigsaw
puzzle to show me the way to a better
life i had been to many seminars and
time management as a lawyer yet i had
never heard the philosophy of time
mastery that julian was now sharing with
me
time management was not just something
to focus on at the office and discarded
closing time
it was a holistic system that could make
all areas of my life more balanced and
fulfilling
i would not only be far more productive
i would be far happier
that brings me to another point don't
let others steal your time
learn to say no
having the courage to say no to the
little things in life will give you the
power to say yes to the big things
what about procrastination
all too often i keep putting off the
things that i don't like doing
it is human nature to do the things that
feel good and avoid the things that feel
bad
but as i said earlier the most
productive people in this world have
cultivated the habit of doing the things
that less productive people don't like
doing even though they too might not
like doing them i stopped and thought
deeply about the principle i had just
heard
perhaps procrastination was not my
problem
maybe my life had simply become too
complex
julian sensed my concern
yogi rahman told me that those who are
masters of their time live simple lives
a hurried frenzied pace is not what
nature intended
while he firmly believed that lasting
happiness could be reached only by those
who were effective and set definite aims
for themselves living a life rich with
accomplishment and contribution did not
have to come through sacrifice of peace
of mind
this is what i found so fascinating
about the wisdom i was hearing it
allowed me to be more productive and yet
fulfill my spiritual longings
i started to open up myself even more to
julian
you have always been honest and
forthright with me so i will be the same
with you
i don't want to give up my practice and
my house and my car to be happier and
more satisfied
i like my toys and the material things
i've earned they are my rewards for all
the hours i have worked over the years
but i feel empty
i really do
there is so much i could do with my life
you know i'm almost 40 and i have never
been to the grand canyon or the eiffel
tower
i can't even remember the last time i
took a long quiet walk by myself after a
snowfall just to hear the sounds and to
enjoy the sensations
then simplify your life julian suggested
sympathetically
apply the ancient ritual of simplicity
to every aspect of your world
too many people are dreaming of some
magical rose garden on the horizon
rather than enjoying the one growing in
their backyards
what a
tragedy any suggestions
that i will leave to your own
imagination oh and that reminds me of
another thing i do to make sure my life
stays calm and simple what's that
i love to have a quick nap in the
afternoon i find it keeps me energetic
refreshed and youthful
i guess you could say that i need my
beauty sleep julian laughed
beauty has never been one of your strong
points
a sense of humor has always been one of
yours and for this i commend you
i think yogi ramen said it best when he
said
laughter opens your heart and soothes
your soul
no one should ever take life so
seriously that they forget to laugh at
themselves
julian had one final thought to share on
the subject of time
perhaps most importantly john stop
acting like you have 500 years to live
develop a death bed mentality
when you adopt a deathbed mentality you
live every day as if it was your last
the deathbed question alone has the
power to change your life
it will energize your days and bring a
rush of zest and spirit to all that you
do
powerful stuff
here's more there is a simple remedy to
break the spell of frustration that
plagues so many people
act as if failure is impossible and your
success will be assured
be brave and set no limits on the
workings of your imagination
never be a prisoner of your past
become the architect of your future
you will never be the same
as the city started to awaken and the
morning grew into full bloom my ageless
friend started to show the first signs
of weariness after night spent sharing
his wisdom with an eager student
i had been astonished by julian's
stamina his boundless energy and his
endless enthusiasm
we are moving to the end of yogi ramen's
magical fable and approaching the time
when i must leave you he said gently
are you going to tell your partners that
you have returned home i asked my
curiosity getting the better of me
probably not julian replied
i'm so different from the julian mantle
they knew
they wouldn't recognize me
you really are a new man i agreed
chuckling inwardly as i pictured this
mystical monk adorned in the traditional
robes of savannah stepping into the
striking red ferrari of his former life
a new being is probably even more
accurate
i don't see the distinction i confess
there is an ancient saying in india
we are not human beings having a
spiritual experience
we are spiritual beings having a human
experience
i see what i am
i am no longer in the world
the world is in me
i'm going to have to chew on that one
for a while i said in total honesty not
quite comprehending what julian was
talking about
sure
i understand my friend
a time will come when you are clear on
what i am saying
if you follow the principles i have
revealed to you and apply the techniques
i have offered you will surely advance
along the path of enlightenment
you will see your life for what it
really is
a small blip on the canvas of eternity
and you will come to see clearly who you
are and the ultimate purpose of your
life
which is
to serve of course
listen to your conscience it will tell
you that your calling in life is
ultimately selfless service to others in
some form or another
my mission is to spread the ancient
wisdom of the sages of savannah to all
those who need to hear it this is my
purpose
the fire of knowledge at kindled
julian's spirit
he was so passionate so committed and so
fervent about what he was saying that it
was reflected even in his physical
dimension
his transformation from a frail old
litigator to a vital young adonis was
not brought about by a simple change in
his diet or a daily dose of some quick
fix exercise plan
he had found the secret that people
through the ages have been searching for
it was more than the secret of youth
fulfillment or even happiness
julian had discovered the secret of the
self
the ultimate purpose of life
the sages of savannah were not only the
most youthful people i've ever met
observed julian they were also the
kindest
yogi ramen told me that when he was a
child as he waited for sleep his father
would ask him what good deeds he had
performed through the course of that day
believe it or not if he said that he
hadn't done any his father would request
that he get up and perform some act of
kindness and selfless service before he
was permitted to go to sleep
julian went on one of the most essential
of all the virtues for enlightened
living that i can share with you john is
this one when all is said and done no
matter what you have achieved the
quality of your life will come down to
the quality of your contribution
does this have something to do with the
fresh yellow roses and yogi ramen's
fable of course it does
the flowers will remind you of the
ancient chinese proverb
a little bit of fragrance always clings
to the hand that gives you roses
the meaning is clear when you work to
improve the lives of others you
indirectly elevate your own life in the
process
when you take care to practice random
acts of kindness daily your own life
becomes far richer and more meaningful
to cultivate the sacredness and sanctity
of every day
serve others in some way
are you suggesting that i get involved
in some volunteer work
that's an excellent starting point but
what i'm speaking of is much more
philosophical than that
i'm suggesting that you adopt a new
paradigm of your role on this planet
you're losing me again shed some light
on the term paradigm
i'm not really familiar with it
a paradigm is simply a way of looking at
a circumstance or at life in general
some people see the glass of life as
half empty the optimists see it as half
full
they interpret the same circumstance
differently because they have adopted a
different paradigm
a paradigm is basically the lens through
which you see the events of your life
both external and internal
to dramatically improve the quality of
your life you must cultivate a new
perspective of why you are here on earth
you must realize that there can only be
one real reason for your being here
and that would be to give yourself to
others and to contribute in a meaningful
way julian replied
our world is in the midst of great
change people are trading in money for
meaning
lawyers who used to judge people by the
size of their pocketbooks are now
judging people by the size of their
commitment to others by the size of
their hearts
teachers are leaving the wombs of
secured jobs to nurture the intellectual
growth of needy kids living in the
combat zones we call inner cities
people have heard the clear call for
change people are realizing that they
are here for a purpose and that they
have been given special gifts that will
aid them to realize it
what kind of special gifts
exactly the ones i've been telling you
about all evening an abundance of mental
ability
boundless energy
unlimited creativity and a storehouse of
discipline and a wellspring of
peacefulness
it is simply a matter of unlocking these
treasures and applying them for common
good no to julian
so how can one go about doing good
i'm simply saying that you should make
it a priority to change your world view
so that you stop seeing yourself purely
as an individual and start seeing
yourself as part of the collective
your life moves to a more magical
dimension when you start striving to
make the world a better place
i knew julian had a point
one of the things that was starting to
bother me about practicing law was that
i didn't really feel i was making the
sort of contribution i knew i was
capable of making
i realized that i had ensconced myself
in a middle class cocoon one that
sheltered me from society at large and
one i had grown accustomed to
compassion and daily acts of kindness
will make life far richer julian said
take the time to meditate every morning
on the good you will do for others
during your day
the sincere words of praise to those who
least expect it the gestures of warmth
offered to friends in need the small
tokens of affection to members of your
family all add up to a much more
wonderful way to live
and speaking of friendships make sure
you keep them in constant repair
a person with three solid friends is
very wealthy indeed
i nodded
friends add humor fascination and beauty
to life
good friends are there to help you when
life throws one of its little curves at
you and things look worse than they seem
when i was a busy litigator
i had no time for friends
now i am alone except for you john
when i've just put down a wonderful book
that has moved me deeply i have no one
to share my thoughts with
i have no one to open my soul to when
the sunshine of a glorious autumn day
warms my heart
and fills me with joy
julian quickly caught himself
however regret is not an activity for
which i have any time
i have learned from my teachers and
savannah that every dawn is a new day to
the one who is enlightened
julian's eyes glitter in the hope of
things yet to come
it appeared to me that julian mantle had
indeed been elevated from a human being
passing through life without a care for
anyone
to a spiritual being passing through
life only caring about others
perhaps this was the path that i too was
about to walk
the timeless secret of lifelong
happiness
it had been over 12 hours since julian
had arrived at my house
those 12 hours were without a doubt the
most important of my life
all at once i was feeling exhilarated
motivated
and yes even liberated
i realized that i had not even begun to
explore the reaches of my human
potential
julian's wisdom allowed me the
opportunity to come to grips with the
wounds that were keeping me from living
with the laughter energy and fulfillment
i knew that i deserved
i felt moved
i'll have to leave soon
you have commitments which are pressing
on your time and i have my own work to
tend to julian said apologetically
my work can wait
unfortunately mine can't he said with a
quick smile
but before i leave
i must reveal the final element of yogi
ramen's magical fable
you will recall that the sumo wrestler
fell to the ground
after what seemed like an eternity he
finally regained consciousness when the
marvelous fragrance of the yellow roses
reached his nose
he then jumped to his feet in delight
and was astonished to see a long winding
path studded with millions of tiny
diamonds
of course our friend the sumo wrestler
took the path and in doing so lived
happily ever after
seems plausible i chuckled
yogi rahman's story has a purpose and
the principles it symbolizes are not
only powerful they are highly practical
true i agreed without reservation
the path of diamonds then will serve to
remind you of the final virtue of
enlightened living
by carrying this principle with you
through your daily work you will enrich
your life you will begin to see the
exquisite wonders in the simplest of
things and live with the ecstasy you
deserve
and by carrying out your promise to me
and sharing it with others you will also
allow them to transform their world from
the ordinary into the extraordinary
will this take me a while to learn the
principle itself is strikingly
straightforward to grasp but learning
how to apply it effectively in all your
waking moments will take a couple of
weeks of steady practice okay i'm dying
to hear it
funny you should say that because the
seventh and final virtue is all about
living
the sages of savannah believe that a
truly joyful and rewarding life comes
only through a process they called
living in the now
the most important moment is now learn
to live in it and savor it fully
i understand exactly what you're saying
julian
my mind is always flooded by a million
little thoughts pulling me in a million
different directions it's really
frustrating
why
it tires me out
i guess i just don't have peace of mind
yet i have experienced times when my
mind is fully occupied on only what was
in front of me
often this happened when i was under the
gun to crank out a legal brief and i
didn't have time to think about anything
other than the task at hand
i've also felt this kind of total focus
when i was playing soccer with the boys
and i really wanted to win
hours seemed to pass by in minutes and i
felt centered
it was as if the only thing that
mattered to me was what i was doing in
that very moment come to think of it
these were probably the times when i
felt the most peaceful as well
julian replied
being engaged in a pursuit that truly
challenges you is the surest route to
personal satisfaction but the real key
to remember is that happiness is a
journey not a destination
live for today there will never be
another one quite like it finnish julian
his smooth hands coming together as if
to give a prayer of thanks for being
privy to what he had just said
is that the principle that the path of
diamonds and yogi ramen's fable
symbolizes i asked you can have the life
you deserve the very moment you start to
understand that the path you are
currently walking on is one rich with
diamonds and other priceless treasures
enjoy the beauty and the sacredness of
all that is around you you owe it to
yourself
does that mean that i should stop
setting big goals for my future and
concentrate on the present
no replied julian firmly goals and
dreams for the future are essential
elements in every truly successful life
my point is simply this
never put off happiness for the sake of
achievement
today is the day to seize the moment and
live a life that soars
today is the day to live from your
imagination and harvest your dreams and
please never ever forget the gift of
family
[Music]
i'm not sure i know exactly what you
mean julian
live your children's childhood came the
simple reply
huh i muttered perplexed at the apparent
paradox
few things are as meaningful as being a
part of your children's childhood
what is the point of climbing the steps
of success if you have missed the first
steps of your own kids
what is the use of being known across
the country as a red hot trial lawyer if
your kids don't even know their father
julian offered his voice now quivering
with emotion
i know where if i speak
this last comment floored me
what could this former millionaire
playboy know about being a father
i do know something of the blessings we
call children he said softly
but i always thought you were the city's
most eligible bachelor before you threw
in the towel and gave up your practice
before i was caught up in the illusion
of that fast and furious lifestyle you
know that i was married
yes
he then paused as a child might before
telling his best friend a closely
guarded secret
what you do not know
is that i also had a little daughter
she was the sweetest most delicate
creature i've ever seen in my life
people told me i had a brilliant future
a stunningly beautiful wife and a
wonderful daughter
yet when life seemed to be perfect
it was all taken from me in an instant
for the first time since his return
julian's eternally joyful face was
enveloped in sadness
a single tear began to slide down one of
his bronze cheeks and dripped onto the
velvety fabric of his ruby red robe
you don't have to continue julian i
offered sympathetically placing an arm
around his shoulder to comfort him
the drunk driver who killed my daughter
didn't take away only one precious life
on that sun-soaked october afternoon
he took two
after my daughter's passing my life
unraveled
i started spending every waking moment
at the office foolishly hoping that my
legal career might be the solve for the
pain of a broken heart
my wife who had been my constant
companion since law school
left me
citing my obsession with work
my health deteriorated and i spiraled
into the infamous life that i was
engaged in when we first met
sure i had everything money could
possibly buy but i sold my soul for it i
really did
julian noted emotionally his voice still
choked up
so when you say live your children's
childhood you are basically telling me
to take the time to watch them grow and
flourish that's it isn't it
even today
27 years after she left us while we were
driving her to her best friend's
birthday party i would give anything
just to hear my daughter giggle again or
to play hide and seek like we used to in
our back garden
i would love to hold her in my arms and
softly caress her golden hair
she took a piece of my heart with her
when she left
and though my life has been inspired by
new meaning since i found the way to
enlightenment and self-leadership in
savannah
a day doesn't pass without me seeing the
rosy face of my sweet little girl in the
silent theater of my mind
you have such great kids john
the best gift you could ever give your
children is your love
get to know them again
pretty soon they will be off building
lives and families of their own
then it'll be too late
the time will be gone
julian had struck a cord deep inside of
me
i guess i had known for some time that
my workaholic pace was slowly but
steadily loosening our family ties
piano recitals christmas plays little
league championships had all been traded
for my professional advancement
[Music]
happiness is a journey julian continued
his voice rising once again with the
heat of passion
enjoy the special moments that every day
offers because today this day is all you
have
can anyone learn to live in the now
absolutely
no matter what your current
circumstances might be you can train
yourself to enjoy the gift of living and
fill your existence with the jewels of
everyday life
when you start spending even five
minutes a day practicing the art of
gratitude you will cultivate the
richness of living that you are looking
for
so by giving daily thanks for all of my
assets whether these are material or
spiritual i will develop the habit of
living in the moment
yes this is an effective method for
putting far more living into your life
when you savor the now you kindle the
fire of life that allows you to grow
your destiny
grow my destiny
we all have something we are meant to do
your genius will shine through happiness
will fill your life the instant you
discover your higher purpose and then
direct all your energies towards it
once you are connected to this mission
all your desires will be fulfilled
effortlessly
simply follow the path of your dreams in
full expectation of the bounty that is
certain to flow
this will bring you to your divine
destination this is what i mean by
growing your destiny julian offered
sagely
when i was a young boy my father loved
to read me a fairy tale known as peter
and the magic thread
peter was a very lively little boy
everyone loved him
his family his teachers and his friends
but he did have one weakness
what was that
peter could never live in the moment he
had not learned how to enjoy the process
of life
when he was in school he dreamed of
playing outside
when he was outside playing he dreamed
of his summer vacation
peter constantly daydreamed never taking
the time to savor the special moments
that filled his days
one morning peter was out walking in a
forest near his home
feeling tired he decided to rest on a
patch of grass and eventually dozed off
after only a few minutes of deep sleep
he heard someone calling his name peter
peter came a shrill voice from above
as he slowly opened his eyes he was
startled to see a striking woman
standing above him
she must have been well over 100 years
old and her snow white hair dangled well
below her shoulders like a matted
blanket of wool
and this woman's wrinkled hand was a
magical little ball with a hole in the
center of it and out of the hole dangled
a long golden thread
peter she said
this is the thread of your life
if you pull the thread just a little bit
an hour will pass in seconds
if you pull a little harder whole days
will pass in minutes
and if you pull with all your might
months even years will pass by in days
peter grew very excited at this
discovery
i'd like to have it if i may he asked
the elderly woman quickly reached down
and gave the ball with the magic thread
to the young boy
the next day peter was sitting in the
classroom feeling restless and bored
suddenly he remembered his new toy
as he pulled a little bit of the golden
thread he quickly found himself at home
playing in his garden
realizing the power of the magic thread
peter soon grew tired of being a
schoolboy and longed to be a teenager
with all the excitement that this phase
of life would bring
so again he pulled out the ball and
pulled hard on the golden thread
suddenly he was a teenager with a very
pretty young girlfriend named elise
but peter still wasn't content
he had never learned to enjoy the moment
and to explore the simple wonders of
every stage of his life
instead he dreamed of being an adult
so again he pulled on the thread and
many years was by in an instant
now he found he had been transformed
into a middle-aged adult
elise was now his wife and peter was
surrounded with a house full of kids
but peter also noticed something else
his once jet black hair had started to
turn gray
and his once youthful mother whom he
loved so dearly had grown old and frail
yet peter still could not live in the
moment he had never learned how to live
in the now
so once again he pulled on the magic
thread and waited for the changes to
appear
peter now found that he was a 90 year
old man
his thick dark hair had turned white as
snow and his beautiful young wife elise
had grown old and had passed away a few
years earlier
his wonderful children had grown up and
left home to lead lives of their own
and for the first time in his entire
life
peter realized he had not taken the time
to embrace the wonders of living
he had never gone fishing with his kids
or taken a moonlight stroll with elise
he had never planted a garden or read
those wonderful books his mother had
loved to read
instead he had hurried through life
never resting to see all the good that
was along the way
peter became very sad at this discovery
he decided to go out to the forest where
he used to love to walk as a young boy
to clear his head and warm his spirit
as he entered the forest he noticed that
the little saplings of his childhood had
grown into mighty oaks
the forest itself had matured into a
paradise of nature
he laid down on a small patch of grass
and fell into a deep slumber
after only a minute he heard someone
calling out to him
peter
peter cried the voice he looked up in
astonishment to see that it was none
other than the old woman who had given
him the ball with the magic golden
thread many years earlier
have you enjoyed my special gift she
asked
peter was directing his reply
at first it was fun
but now i hate it
my whole life has passed before my eyes
without giving me the chance to enjoy it
sure there would have been sad times as
well as great times but i haven't had
the chance to experience either
i feel empty inside
i've missed the gift of living
you are very ungrateful said the old
woman
still i will give you one last wish
peter thought for an instant and then
answered hastily
i'd like to go back to being a schoolboy
and live my life over again
he then returned to his deep sleep
again he heard someone calling his name
and opened his eyes
who could it be this time he wondered
when he opened his eyes he was
absolutely delighted to see his mother
standing over his bedside
she looked young healthy and radiant
peter realized that the strange woman of
the forest had indeed granted his wish
and he had returned to his former life
hurry up peter you sleep too much your
dreams will make you late for school if
you don't get up right this minute his
mother admonished
needless to say
peter dashed out of bed on this morning
and began to live the way he had hoped
peter went on to live a full life
one rich with many delights joys and
triumphs
but it all started when he stopped
sacrificing the present for the future
and began to live in the moment
today is your chance to awaken to the
gift of living before it is too late
julian continued
let this new day be the defining moment
of your life the day that you make the
decision once and for all to focus on
what is truly important to you
revive your spirit and start tending to
your soul
this is the way to nirvana
nirvana
the sages of savannah believe that the
ultimate destination of all truly
enlightened souls was a place called
nirvana
actually more than a place the sages
believed nirvana to be a state
one that transcended anything they had
known previously
in nirvana all things were possible
there was no suffering and the dance of
life was played out with divine
perfection
on reaching nirvana the sages felt that
they would step into heaven on earth
this was their ultimate goal in life
julian observed his face radiating a
peaceful almost angelic quality
we're all here for some special reason
he observed prophetically
meditate on what your true calling is
and how you can give yourself to others
start applying the principles and
strategies that i have shared with you
be all that you can be
a time will come when you too will taste
the fruits of that place called nirvana
how will i know when i reach the state
of enlightenment
little hints will appear to confirm your
entrance
you will start to notice the holiness in
everything that is around you the
divinity of a moon beam
the allure of a lush blue sky on a
scorching summer day
the fragrant bloom of a daisy or the
laugh of a mischievous little child
julian
i promise you that the time you have
spent with me will not be in vain
i will dedicate myself to living by the
wisdom of the sages of savannah
and i will keep my promise to you by
sharing all that i have learned
i am speaking from the heart
i give you my word i offered sincerely
feeling the throes of emotion stirring
within
spread the rich legacy of the sages to
all those around you
they will quickly benefit from this
knowledge and improve the quality of
their lives just as you will improve the
quality of yours
and remember
the journey is to be enjoyed
the road is just as good as the end
i let julian continue
yogi ramen was a great storyteller but
there was one story he told me which
stood out amongst the rest
may i share it with you
absolutely
many years ago in ancient india a
maharaja wanted to build a great tribute
to his wife as a sign of his deep love
and affection for her
this man wanted to create a structure
the likes of which the world had never
seen
one that people would admire for
centuries to come
so every day block by block his workers
toiled in the hot sun
and every day the structure started to
look a little more defined a little more
like a monument a little more like a
beacon of love against the azure blue
indian sky
finally after 22 years of daily gradual
progress this palace of pure marble was
complete
guess what i'm speaking of
i have no idea
the taj mahal one of the seven wonders
of the world julian replied
my point is simple
everyone on this planet is a wonder of
the world
every one of us has the potential for
extraordinary achievement happiness and
lasting fulfillment
all it takes are small steps in the
direction of our dreams
like the taj mahal a life overflowing
with wonders is built day by day block
by block
tiny incremental changes and
improvements such as those i've
suggested will create positive habits
positive habits will create results and
results will inspire you towards greater
personal change
begin to live every day as if it was
your last
starting today
learn more laugh more and do what you
truly love to do
do not be denied your destiny for what
lies behind you and what lies in front
of you matter little compared to what
lies within you
without saying another word
julian mantle the millionaire lawyer
turned enlightened monk got up
embraced me like the brother he had
never had and walked out of my living
room into the thick heat of another
scorching summer day
as i sat alone
and collected my thoughts
i noticed that the only evidence i could
find if the sage messenger's
extraordinary visit sat silently on the
coffee table in front of me
it was his empty cup
[Music]
[Music]
you